all right
yo what up reject Nation yo we live are
we live in the house let us know if you
can hear us let us know if you can hear
us koi's got a new haircut
koi's got a new haircut oh Dan v900 he
has sent a 10 super chat I can't okay
when we go to the supers we're gonna let
you know all right guys all right if you
can hear us let us know let me adjust
this a tiny bit koi get it pretty guys
koi what do you think of koi's hair
Laura asked where it is it is on the
floor of my barber well I assume now in
the trash of my barber uh this is the
hair I had for years and I missed it so
much and uh I am very very happy to have
it back he looks sexy as hell doesn't he
feel it feels like me feels like uh
feels like who I am I think we should
get in a fight oh I think we should end
up is that what this hair breaks at me
like this is a guy I want to fight yes
um okay guys uh ladies and gentlemen
really quick
what I wanted to say is
that koi's gonna make an announcement
while I grab something so I can do the
backup recording on the audio you got
okay do you want to say what's happening
tell them about the Comic-Con
citizens of the reject Nation we have
been teasing it for quite some time and
we can now officially tell you Saturday
1 pm
PST at Comic-Con we will be in the
auditorium of the Neil Morgan Auditorium
officially at San Diego Comic-Con Neil
Morgan Auditorium the Central Library of
San Diego Comic-Con uh it's a pretty big
room so uh come through because it's uh
they're like hey these guys they really
filled up WonderCon let's let's give
them a bigger room and we're like hey
we've earned that but also we want you
there and Corey's going to be like five
minutes late to it uh yeah he's doing a
whole age I'm literally hosting a whole
H as our panel starts but I will be
there it'll just be a few minutes late
so I'm gonna have to physically you know
gallivant but uh it's cool that we're
literally gonna be I can tell the people
at all I should go over yeah there you
go you leave Hall h you go to the
library there'll be no one there at our
panel and then suddenly there's going to
be a swarm of people running behind yeah
this is insane I'm hoping this goes well
who are these guys
you're really insisted every one of them
who are these rejects are they real uh
so yeah please please come through we
are very excited San Diego is uh
something that means a lot to me San
Diego Comic-Con is something that was
always a pipe dream as a kid to even
attend so the fact that we are are
having a panel like I've hosted panels
and I've attended panels and I've slept
in the whole H line but to have a real
rejects panel there feels like we did
like obviously uh my publicist who I
love dearly helped but like we have a
panel at Saturday at San Diego Comic-Con
that's like such an honor so please come
through if you're anywhere in California
can't wait for koi's arms to be even
bigger that day hell yeah getting that
plump all right guys well enough of that
boring stuff about us having a Comic-Con
panel let's kick off this live stream
officially ladies and gentlemen if you
are here please be here by leaving a
like that would mean a lot and uh it's
been a while since we've been live and I
think the next one that'll be John and
Coy yeah there's gonna be a point I
decided to recovered koi looks like he's
about to take over the early 2000s box
office
uh next week yeah uh we've got a big one
me and John what is it oh yeah yeah yeah
the DC animated one yeah we're gonna be
ranking so you guys uh love my ranking
videos in koi's comic Corner John and I
have been watching the entirety of the
DC General Animated Universe but we just
concluded the specific
dcamu corner of that Universe we're
gonna be ranking the amus and uh that's
gonna be a lot so I'm very excited about
it and we're still building up to the
day where koi learns how to do this so
he can do a live stream by himself uh so
thank you guys for everyone who's here
and thank you to all who contribute to
our super chats and streamlabs we just
saw another one coming thank you guys so
much like playbacks on these are weird
and so is like Google AdSense on them so
like the super chats and streamliners
are definitely welcome and we got so
many last time we kept us on live stream
for longer it's always longer than we
expect but we never end a stream without
without doing all of them that's just
the way we roll anyway guys uh let me
just address this a tiny bit there we go
okay sweet sauce well here's what we're
going to talk about today for sure
um uh before we carry into anything else
we have uh the main topics are here in
this photo as you can see we got Ryan
Reynolds set photos he got rumors about
Wolverine in his yellow suit and then uh
apparently Robert Downey Jr was spotted
on set for Captain America four guys and
then you know of course some Superman
Legacy talk that we got to be having
right now let's kick it off with the
main topic of the day
um Ryan Reynolds so koi what do you
think of this atrocious new suit that he
has atrocious atrocious tiny gosh that
are causing such a problem people were
like new MCU suit and I was like it's
just Infinity pull up another photo
because I can't quite tell the
difference between the two also the
photo that like is out there that's like
all bright is is a very saturated this
one is
like by the way I don't know if you guys
know this here's a little BTS on running
YouTube page the thumbnails are an
insane journey and it's really hard
because if they're not pretty it's like
not as likely to click just
subconsciously this man hustles on these
thumbnails this is gorgeous I'll
appreciate that like truly uh now
Deadpool in my opinion has one of the
best super suits of all super suits and
I think that the slight tweaks the
color's a little brighter but it's not
nearly as different as a lot of people
that are pulling people are pulling like
promo Stills that are like the finished
movie from like a Set photo and they're
going like ah they've changed everything
they've literally added some gold
accoutrement to his uh to his knuckles
he's got a little bit more uh gold on
his accessories he's also got a slightly
different chess piece but overall is a
very subtle change and I think honestly
it looks a little more comic accurate I
actually like this loot a sight better
like it's not a crazy change but I like
the slight changes
um and most of all what I'm getting from
this is I called this years ago I said
in 20 2018 they were going to do
Deadpool kills the fox Universe when
they started talking merger why are you
insisting that that is what you get from
these set photos what is what is it
about the photo okay there's a shot of
Ryan Reynolds standing and this sounds
so dumb but there's a shot of Rider
riddle standing in front of a forest but
the forest looks just like the forest
from Logan I know Hugh Jackman has also
said he would not ruin the ending of
Logan so I think this shot is shot right
here I think that's Deadpool pulling
that in yeah let me pull it up uh Wally
grabs this I think this is literally a
moment where we are having Ryan Reynolds
as Wade Wilson trying to gather
Wolverine and he can't get the Wolverine
he knows because he's dead so I think
this is Wade Wilson literally
discovering the dead body of Logan to
make it Canon that the Wolverine we made
in the film is a different Wolverine I
think there's gonna be multiple
Wolverines but I think Logan stays Dead
uh I think this shot right here the
force behind him is going to be the
woods at the end of Logan and I think we
get a comic accurate Wolverine I get I
think we get a very fun different
playful uh Wolverine I think we might
even get like the X-Men animated series
like looking at Gene gray well I think
we're gonna get a lot of different
Wolverines but I think this specific
image shows that the Logan that we know
is dead you got it all from this one
shot not even kidding this one shot with
a little tree behind it where it's MCU
and you could literally put him anywhere
that's what I got and you said that's
what we got end of Logan
going on right now okay so the math
checks out years ago I said five years
ago now I said Deadpool kills the fox
universe and now we find out Elektra is
in it confirming that we're getting Fox
characters years ago I said the only way
to have Deadpool be R-rated in the MCU
is by having him out of continuity if
Deadpool's killing the fox universe that
means that the character would know he's
in a movie which would allow him to be
bleeped in PG-13 movies but be R-rated
in his own movies this also allows the
fourth wall breaking to be logical
without messing up the continuity of the
MCU and it allows Ryan Reynolds the man
himself to control the Press rollout
which I think he deserves if you'll
notice d23 was only a week before
Deadpool 3 was announced with Hugh
Jackman I guarantee you Marvel wanted to
have Deadpool be announced as a big
spectacle but Ryan Reynolds like nah nah
I'm maximum effort media I control the
Press roll out because I think he's the
best at it so I would say he's
controlling the narrative in and out of
continuity and in and out of the
narrative by making this for the
storyline all right from this image well
I believe you
okay so what do you think about the
rumors about him being in the yellow
suit uh Wolverine oh I think that okay
so if you think it would be cheesy I
think they could pull it off I think
they can pull it off and I think Hugh
Jackman wanted it the whole time like oh
yeah there's teeth for the Wolverine he
was supposed to be in Spiderman
oh yeah that's right that's right that's
how long this goes back of like Kevin
feige was the reason Hugh Jackman has
Comic accurate hair he fought on set to
make sure it was accurate that's how
long Kevin feige's had our backs he was
literally supposed to be the first
crossover cameo in the first Spider-Man
Wolverine was supposed to walk by like
on the ground so I think the idea of a
suit has been percolating for literally
the entire modern superhero era 2001
Spider-Man came out so 22 years I think
Hugh Jackman's been fighting for a suit
I think we're finally gonna get a if not
a couple suits of Wolverine all right
all right well there you have it guys I
think he would look absolutely that's
the one one thing left to fulfill I feel
like about Hugh Jackman yeah right
there's it's as much as I feel like
we're done with the character like
whatever you do with the character no
this is yeah to me I think what he
really wants is to cross over with a
Marvel Cinematic Universe yeah and of
course rock that yellow suit it was teas
at the end of the Wolverine and or
what's the teeth at the end of the
Wolverine or wizard
they wanted it to happen and it would be
the most comic accurate reflection but
the other thing was since we're on the
Deadpool 3 subject that we have to talk
about oh wait I see there's a super chat
in there we'll want to make sure don't
want to over don't over answer don't
over answer things we will get to them
um ASAP right away you know what how
about we how about we run through the
mill on the on the food that we've
gotten so far okay so I want to play
some of these audios yeah I know they're
very good I mean we ran late because I
was like I have audio ideas for the
super chats and they're worth the delay
I got a 10 I got a ten dollar one a 15
one and a twenty dollar one uno memento
por favor while Greg wraps well Greg
readjusts the world for everyone here
um in the meantime Coy read off some
things that are happening in the chat
right now uh let's see let's see uh
what's this and why do I care I don't
know why are you here koi makes a lot of
sense thank you very much love the
haircut koi looks good I appreciate that
Chris Pratt be a good Booster Gold he is
my fantastic boost school just for like
making it people angry and also the
James Gunnison doesn't think I'd be so
mad at uh koi should work for Marvel
seriously I should have been perhaps
consulted on this thing I pitched uh
five years ago but also like it's what's
really funny to me is I pitched this to
Rob liefeld and Rob liefeld and I are on
camera saying like we should really
reach out to Kevin feige and now I'm
like did he see this interview because
it was legit five years ago uh and like
Ryan Reynolds obviously is a big
Deadpool fan to the point where Deadpool
kills the Marvel universe is probably in
his Pantheon so I'm not saying I wrote
this I'm just saying I could have helped
uh by the way I also think that Ryan
Reynolds is going to be running maybe
the best marketing campaign ever because
I think now more than ever Marvel is
going to need the Deadpool bump I think
he's gonna basically be the the um Iron
Man of the fox say you were so good at
filling the time
I'm like man I don't know
it's kind of quiet normally I'm like
kind of like just a triplet be cool it's
gonna be fine
do you know why do you know my you know
my thing it's a horrible name but do you
know the reason behind that behind what
why I'm like I'm so focused on dead air
why uh okay Shameless name drop first
one of the uh hour uh when I was at the
Ford versus Ferrari Premiere I was
talking to Harrison Ford you know that
guy and uh there was a moment where I
thanked him for how he treats
journalists and I think he thought I was
like joking or like like making fun of
him sure and he looked down at me kind
of quizzically and I was like no no like
the way you trick journalist means I
have a job because people get seen as
not being able to do their job because
you call them out on it like you're
aggressive toward journalists and I
think that's the bar like if someone's
sitting down with an actor like Harrison
Ford they should do their job and
Harrison Ford doesn't let him get off of
it so I thanked him and I was sincere
and he turned around and there was this
moment where I was like oh no of angered
Harrison Ford and he gave me the point
which is terrible you've got the first
point four points and he said something
I'll never forget and he's the Gemini
Cricket on my shoulder now he went I got
one rule if there's dead air it's theirs
so now as a journalist it's mine so I
never let there be dead air because
Harrison Ford he's my Jiminy Cricket
don't worry I'm gonna get this it'll
eventually smooth out
um you know you just got to give me
five seconds so you know how it is
normally I'm like we embrace the rocky
side of of this we're so early in the
Stream
I have readjusted this so many times and
it's it is it is very very often but um
don't worry guys we got this I just want
to get to that Jennifer Garner question
oh
I'm very excited fill the silence uh of
course you talked to Harrison Ford who
haven't you talked to uh you know I
haven't talked to Barack Obama I would
like to talk to Obama uh I've never met
Dr Dre you haven't talked to Barack uh I
would really really like to meet
um uh Michelle Pfeiffer not Michelle
Pfeiffer
um who else is there
um this is good cool I'm trying to think
of unnamed props uh you cut yeah bro I
like that I like that comment I
appreciate it we're not gonna talk about
Deadpool 3 News no we're just getting to
the squatter to make sure to get to the
super Channel I hate it when we're like
oh we're someone committed uh provided a
Super Chat and I feel like always bad
when someone has when we've already
answered it on our own yeah
um I also have more theories about
Deadpool so I'm hoping they're in the
chat so ask Dad pull questions yeah yeah
yeah we got this we got don't worry I
just wanted to make sure to get there
but really quick
Dan v900
we got a 10.
[Music]
from the Pitch Perfect 3 reaction you
brought up how the first one was raunch
here with the code right we're keeping
this on a completely different subject
uh the first one was rauncher with the
comedy speaking of raunchy comedies
Joyride is out right now and it's so
good the OG style was Joy [__] Club I
want you guys to know that so many
people have told us like I remember we
were talking at the mission we literally
were talking about this at another event
and uh there were a lot of people who
were saying like this it's one of the
funniest movies like in in a very very
long time and I decided a long time ago
I'm already going to be covering it here
as a reaction on the channel it's a
comedy man and we don't cover be
surprised they don't react to that many
comedies will it be koi in the video
will it be John who knows I have waited
to see it but thank you Dan v900 uh
let's see right here Chef C would never
wish for the end of this uh but thank
you for the Super Chat by the way uh
what are each of your dreams hopes
Ambitions in life after RR or alternate
timeline without real read rejects
what's your dream life my real ambition
is to really get the you know it's
looking great I feel like this career
Endeavor that I have is is really solid
uh screenwriting right now more than
ever it seems like it's the best
profession
yeah but that is my main uh aspiration
and then I also really do want to create
a graph uh just like a couple weeks ago
you and I were sharing our graphic novel
ideas kind of uh in depth of what we
would want to create and uh one day I
feel like that'll be something coin I do
ultimately collaborate on in some
capacity and I and I've got a screenplay
I want Greg to look at that I used to
write and uh I really value his opinion
as a writer and as a man so I want him
to so we're both kind of like mainly as
a man unless as a writer I mean you know
it's objective but uh my main dream hope
ambition
um is I really want to do what James
Lipton did for acting like actors
getting that credibility and their
connection like I feel like James Lipton
humanized actors in a real way but for
uh genre content I want to give
Integrity to genre content I feel like
there's this weird Gap where if
someone's good in a movie but it's in a
it's in a movie that happens to be
adapted from a comic there's an asterisk
and I hate that because most movies are
either adapted from like a book a story
uh true uh that like there's so many
things that adapt so the fact that
Comics make it an asterisk drives me
insane so I want to be a talk show host
that specifies that genre content is
just as worthy Lord of the Rings is not
any different than a Meryl Streep joint
and uh I hate that caveat so a talk show
host is my Big Goal we got something in
the works to demonstrate that he just
did an interview with someone and I can
guarantee you it's it's the best
interview of this actor you guys will
ever see I don't mean that in any
hyperbolic way pavender Meyer saying
recommendations thank you papa Meyer
um
reactions Batman year One that's already
on the list All-Star Batman uh Superman
I mean I think that's on the list
already Superman red Sun and Batman or
Harley Quinn those are all on the list
haven't gotten would appreciate the
Super Chat yeah I appreciate the the
oomph we know you're gonna be excited
there I love how a lot of these have
nothing to do with the main things
there's one question in the super chats
this list that we're really trying to
get to
but I love the questions that are coming
in so far so thank you guys
um raccoon shampoo is saying uh oh wait
it's a 10.
chat
I've been thinking about this all night
what Star Wars species would be the
tastiest if we're talking in terms of
food
um I okay I'm gonna take this in a
different direction in a way that won't
get us demonetized a Twilight would be
the tastiest one there's just something
about them though when you see them
you're like I don't know what it is
about this creature but they're so sexy
that's Twilight is I do yeah I like that
that's not the answer I was thinking
porgs look delicious oh they'd be the
best to eat they're like chickens I'm
using tasting you're going tasty I
respect
what's the what's the species that are
like the blue aliens that are all like
sensual like in the Cantina
that's a Twilight we're on the same page
but I thought it was another thing
entirely I thought it was the green ones
oh no they can be blue and green yeah
yeah
I was wrong and right simultaneously
we have the same taste in Aliens Greg
let's see here uh thank you Wesley
Marshall uh thank you Wesley be sure to
watch Constantine House of mystery it's
part of the DC AMU I feel it's going to
be a really good live stream uh someone
said can we start the main topics we did
we did a Deadpool section we rewind back
we did start the main topics we will get
there we just we're trying to get to
there's one specific in here that we saw
that I want to make sure we get to it uh
it's part of the DC AMU Constantine one
specifically the rest of the shorts are
not connected but great I believe that
is on the list how's the mystery I'd
love to see it because I really love the
Constantine like subplot and the through
line through the universe so I maybe we
could do that like right before the uh
the live stream or something those will
be rising up in ranks again here all
right here we go Deadpool
chat
Deadpool 3 will be the let me adjust
this uh Deadpool 3 will be the only
Marvel movie to make billion dollars in
the next two to three years Avengers
movies might be delayed so we might not
see them anytime soon and the build up
is underwhelming that's true I do think
the build up to it has been a tad
underwhelming it's like we're excited by
the title of it yeah but there was a
such a solid build up to Infinity
warning even though we didn't know
exactly what the plot was knowing the
Infinity Stones were out in the ether
and the whole universe and somehow this
is going to collectively bring everyone
together the threat is not as concise or
clear-cut but I feel like Deadpool 3
could be the first of Deadpool movie to
actually break the billion dollar market
close just the fact that you have
Wolverine and Deadpool in the same movie
side by side together within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
it seems like the TVA is definitely
going to be in there yeah as you
mentioned I think uh there's another
Cameo that just was reported by
Hollywood Reporter that we are going to
dive into in just a minute but that that
alone is letting you know that this
might actually deliver more than what we
all expected Multiverse of Madness to
deliver on and in terms of Ryan Reynolds
nostalgic yeah yeah and I think he's
going to want to deliver on that yeah I
think personally this is going to be a
billion dollar movie for all the reasons
you just mentioned but also it's kind of
an anti-fatigue like there's certain
movies that are like oh I can laugh with
and at it like I feel like Deadpool's
gonna acknowledge superhero fatigue
Deadpool's gonna lean into all the
multiversal stuff we wanted Deadpool's
gonna be kind of the answer to the
questions we've had I feel like across
the spider verse was much more than
Multiverse of Madness we wanted but
there's still people that have that like
animated asterisk uh and then there's
also people that like don't see that as
part of the universe so I think that
Deadpool is going to be what we wanted
Multiverse what we wanted Thor what we
wanted Deadpool 2 even to be because I
personally like Deadpool one more than
Deadpool 2. I think going back to the
root of Deadpool and what he is but then
going huge with it and then tying in
Hugh Jackman coming back there's no way
this doesn't make a billion like I think
it's on almost guaranteed that's a
hundred percent gonna make I feel like
this one might be it's been a while
since Marvel's had a billion dollars
it's been a while since Disney's had a
billion dollars yeah there's a reason
they moved it up seven months there's
also a reason that if they're rapping
soon the confidence in this must have
been insane I guarantee Sean Levy and
Ryan Reynolds were reading or getting
the hell out of this before they even
filmed I think ADR is going to be like a
lot of people are worried about the
writer strike which everyone should be
but I think with Ryan Reynolds
particularly there's so much work under
the mask that you can ADR jokes later
and you can also film a lot of options
on set that are written so I'm not as
worried about that as others but I think
that this is Comfortably Marvel's
biggest thing on the books which is
crazy that Deadpool's Bigger Than The
Avengers
I mean it's kind of like Avengers
crossover I think it makes Avengers so
big is you know those crossing the cross
no fun fact in the comics after the
Avengers did so well Deadpool comics
were also doing very well because they
came out pretty much simultaneously and
in the comic books Deadpool was actually
funding The Avengers with his movie
money like they made it cannon that
Deadpool had the movie money and he was
funding The Avengers we must move on koi
okay
Collide thank you hey guys who's your
pick for the DCU Batman George Clooney
obviously I mean the flash already
established
uh no I I I'm going to go on the train
I'm going to Champion hardcore for
Jensen Ackles if he wants it to as uh it
gets closer I do feel like Jensen Ackles
is more and more likely especially with
how James Gunn made it very clear that
he was looking at Fan responses like I
feel like that that tweet of racial
Brosnahan and David Corn sweat from
three years ago is very indicative of
how plugged in he is and I also think
Jensen Ackles is uh passionate about
fandom I really want someone that cares
about like us and Jensen Ackles has
voiced him very well so there's a
hundred reasons if you guys can't tell
this all these live streams to build up
to koi doing the solo
when I say something like that but I was
like no also we switch off doing them
it's been fun but yeah one one day on
the ones and twos we finally got to it
this is the one that I was like we're
gonna bring it up and then it just had
me redirect the whole structure
uh all right Sidra uh zadim uh
he she I'm not sure cool thank you for
the Super Chat uh I read that Jennifer
Garner is coming back as Elektra in
Deadpool 3. see there were rumors
earlier that Ben Affleck was spotted on
set for Deadpool three and at first I
was like all right I'm not really sure
what's it I mean it could could not be
true that maybe they're just buddies I
had a right I had a hard time
um truly believing like is what is he
showing up for he could just be set
visiting in some way right and then he
just did the Batman thing and like I I I
I think he's willing to take the piss
out of it something that some people
might forget about Ben Affleck is he can
take the piss out of himself like one of
the things plays Ben Affleck so well one
of the things that made me like him so
much was when Gili came out I'll never
forget uh he was on the Jay Leno tonight
show did you ever see this he's on a
Tonight Show and he's like it's getting
such bad reviews but I wanted to read
the good reviews and he just read like
the most the worst reviews it was such a
hilarious way to handle the bad
publicity the movie was getting and then
all the stuff he's done with Kevin Smith
where he makes fun of himself right so
then I and it seems like the way they
talk like Jennifer Garner and him even
though they're divorced they seem like
they talk on good terms raising their
kids and they seem like close
and then Hollywood Reporter confirms
they they broke it I think it's
Hollywood Reporter variety one of those
two main Outlets but it was it's
confirmed in one of the major Outlets
that Jennifer Garner is coming back as
Elektra in Deadpool three which to me
what okay then Ben Affleck must be doing
a cameo without the other that must be
true confirm that Ben Affleck is
certainly now going to be appearing in
Deadpool 3 as a Matt Murdock or
Daredevil which again more to the
Credence that okay we are going to be
exploring the fox universe and killing
them off what a perfect way to do it and
I how insane is it you rewind the clock
to the fox Universe falling apart how
bad Electro is pan can you imagine
telling even when Deadpool 1 came out
being like hey and how we're gonna find
out Electra gets confirmed like what a
weird choice of any of them but it does
seem to lock in Deadpool does kill the
fox Universe I think that's happening
and with Elektra coming back that opens
up the door to all sorts of options Halo
gonna be so mad
but I also think this does allow out for
some fun like multiversal hijinks of I
think we're gonna get cameos from people
that wanted to play these characters
yeah I think we're gonna see a lot of
things that never came to be that's cool
rocket Fox if they do share a scene
that's I'd love that I think that's
really cool uh but you know if they if
they do have a scene together yeah
um that means they're they got to hang
out with their kids on set yeah uh
someone achy tomchi why not Charlie Cox
because he's not the fox yeah Daredevil
uh that's different there I mean
Daredevil will probably interact with
Deadpool now that he's in the universe
but not here I swear to God they better
give us a Nick Cage Cameo and not that
goddamn CGI [__] a real one tangible
like one thing that we've been as you
guys uh have been doing the DC Animated
Universe movies because I've seen most
of those already yeah
um you say I don't really remember but I
but I've definitely seen most of them
um but like we've also been trying to
wrap up like what other fox movies have
we missed you know so I just watched
like Spirit of engines it's so crazy
which I like Ghost Rider spirit events
it's a blast the way they shot the
visuals in that yeah the craft directors
Neville Dean and Taylor just going to
work I thought it was really I actually
have fun
um and then yeah like going with this
one based off the same subject uh
Panthers rule 95 thank you for the Super
Chat my friend hope the original
Fantastic Fours and Deadpool 3 and if
Chris Evans is in it my life will be
complete Ryan Reynolds similar to Dwayne
Johnson is one of those people who's
really plugged into what the fans are
thinking and saying and kind of hoping
for and I feel like he actually did pay
attention to some of the response that
people felt a little bit let down with
by Multiverse of Madness and he's also
you can also see the opportunity of what
to do with inheriting the fox universe
and this this would be the first
clear-cut sign right with this yeah I
mean other than like Patrick Stewart
appearing this is the this is Deadpool
three right a fox Universe movie
continuing in the MCU it's the biggest
things to do and people don't realize
this it's not just Evan Peters yeah yeah
they're they're doing a real thing I
also think because of how many cameos we
get in movies nowadays people realize
the scope this is an entire Studio how
to die for this to occur like the fox
mutant Universe was like 10 movies it
was an enormous thing it was before the
MCU this was a giant thing that had to
completely go away for the opportunity
for Deadpool 3 to exist this is the
biggest crossover in cinema history this
is bigger than Avengers this is The
Avengers plus Another Universe so I just
don't know if people realize because of
how kind of desensitized we are what
this actually can be and my original
pitch was we see Chris Evans show up and
everyone waits for him to like yell
Avengers Assemble or hold the shield and
then he flames on I think that'd be the
funniest way to start this I think after
being able to get him in a cameo for
free guy yeah I think they're homies and
like also the opportunity to bring in
Michael B Jordan and have a him flame on
after Chris Evans like there's so many
things that'd be hilarious and I was
saying before I think cameos like Jon
Hamm is Mr Sinister things that we never
actually got to see yeah so this is
going to be I can't wait now we do got
more Super chats that we got to go
through but uh I did want to talk really
quick about the Robert Downey Jr
um the hymn visiting set because that
seems likely that that really did happen
hold on let me readjust this entire
setup okay let me re I I actually have
not seen the electro movie good timing
I mean it's not I don't know worth it
but I'd certainly being talked about I
think you should watch it before the
Deadpool 3 movie you've got seven months
let me just I'm just gonna temporarily
keep it like this I know it's not
appealing on screen it's gonna be like
this temporarily over under 30 Deathpool
or gwenpool shows up uh I think gwenpool
is actually pretty likely with how
popular When Stacy is homie I just said
we gotta talk about a specific news I
was vibing for time because you uh it's
not a very small I don't know
and oh my God I can't wait because we
got a good 20. oh it's coming all right
here we go it is bigger than Avengers
someone in the chat um so Robert Downey
Jr
he was apparently in uh on set for
Captain America four and
I some people are thinking that this
might mean he's doing a cameo for the
movie have you heard about this I
haven't this is the first I've seen it
and the first I've seen him so
there was no Set photo but no one was
the person who said it was apparently
was working security or some [__] I
mean you always take these this [__]
with a grain of salt I mean the Ben
Affleck thing I took with the grain of
salt too and then apparel now yeah holy
[__] yeah
um even if he was on set
I heard something about someone
explained it was on on Twitter someone
was explaining to me and I think they
were quoting with John campy it was
talking about is how Robert Downey Jr
has some new car show or something like
that yeah it's about like clean energy
vehicles and they're awesome like his
cars these retrofitted old cars he was
showing up there with some kind of cool
car or whatever so he could have just
been there to shoot some segments Chris
he gave him those Heavens a car and I
feel like he would have been a lot more
private discreet and secretive if he
actually was showing up right to be
cameoing as you know as Tony Stark right
that'd be massive or maybe they would
want something like that to sort of leak
so they can start to get buzzed around
the movie right yeah you can see it
going either scenario but uh what is
your thoughts on it if and if if he is
to return as rock as as Robert danger if
he is to return as Iron Man or even a
cameo or appearance there because I feel
like it'd probably show up in secret
Wars in some way but if he is to return
in there
is this the movie for him to do it I
don't think it's the movie to do it okay
I think it I think personally it
undermines the moment that will probably
happen in secret Wars or King Dynasty I
also think it kind of undermines the
impact of the first cat movie with
Anthony Mackey it feels like you know if
you don't let cat be his own thing it's
kind of the Spider-Man problem where
people were complaining like ah
Spider-Man's always got cameos from MCU
like I keep hearing that this is the
most Avengers in a movie Sense Avengers
is Cap four so if you keep throwing
things at the you know spaghetti at the
wall I want it to feel Espionage and I
think you know you could have Iron Man
maybe in a flashback but even that'll
undermine the impact of when he comes
back so I personally never want Daddy Jr
to come back I think I think it'll never
never I think it undermines his death
but if it has to happen I think it
should be an Avengers film I honestly
think that Chris Evans and Downey Jr I
want them to be able to be their own
people I feel like every time I open
Instagram because I'm a fan of Downey Jr
the man separate of Iron Man I think his
work in everything like Chaplin and Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang is my favorite comedy I
like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang more than 98 of
Marvel movies I'm a fan of him because
he actually rescues a [__] ton of
animals does he did you watch this David
yeah oh I didn't know they were all
rescues I didn't connect that might have
been rest it doesn't matter either way
he like raises a bunch of animals but I
think Downey the man doesn't get to be
Downey anymore because you click on his
Instagram people are like oh Iron Man's
getting old I'm like yeah the human
being that is down here has traveled
through time so I I want in that way I
want him to just not yeah if he's some
people are saying like a flashback
because Stark has been supplying Ross's
here for Blonsky and some devices see I
don't it just feels so underwhelming it
feels underwhelming come back for just a
simple flashback that that would make
more sense if he was still a part of
everything and he's got something in the
in the future where you can just have
him Cameo for some flashback or
something
this is the return a simple little
flashback 2006 something that could have
been explained by a character just
saying right Tony Stark provided me with
it bring Jeff Bridges back if you want
to do a cameo from flashback yeah yeah
yeah so yeah I personally think a
multiversal like old man um Stark which
is canon in the comics in The Avengers
old man Stark is a big character that'd
be something but I still would rather
not sure true true all righty well um
let's get back to it and then uh remind
me to talk about some Superman Legacy
stuff okay and a little bit okay uh but
yeah no I saw some supers coming in so I
want to make sure we get to that koi yes
okay Tom Cruise for Iron Man I think
that'd be a really fun thing in Deadpool
I think honestly it'd be more likely to
happen in a brief Deadpool Cameo than
Secret Wars because I've been like Ryan
Reynolds weirdly has like the most pull
ever
um especially since you look at Deadpool
one that was around Reynolds coming off
two of the worst flops of his career and
Deadpool was literally made for 58
million dollars and made 850 million
dollars so I think the only person that
has as much pull as as Downey is Ryan so
that would be the way I'd want uh Tom
Cruise Cameo to happen that also kind of
implies it wouldn't carry on into the
movies I'm always worried like people
are like George Clooney as Batman and
actually think so uh I think people
realize that like I think it needs to
happen in a spoof setting not an
Avengers multiversal setting for people
to to grasp it I said I feel like that
was a terrible call on their rent to do
that especially so funny I think it was
funny too but I think it confused a lot
of people I don't understand how it
confused people what do you mean because
it's because they said there's a new
Batman coming up and it's same director
yeah but it's so clear that he's like
showing that it's in a Multiverse and
that like it's a joke it literally the
only line that's spoken to him is like
you're not bleeping Batman and I'm like
well that's a commentary I just don't
understand how people are like oh
there's our Batman I would love it if he
is
see if they do that then I think it's
even funny that would that would make me
so happy all right we're just running a
little quick refresher here guys
um and then yeah some Superman he said
what was James Gunn saying you follow
James Gunn's news I do yeah okay so uh
I'll just throw it to you when the time
comes when the time comes to talk about
the Superman Legacy stuff James Gunn is
the Kevin foggy in DC I've been saying
it for years very excited about it being
official all right all right we got this
thank you guys for everyone who's been
contributing
and I like how it's on topic now yeah
okay let's see here Nathan pellifelli uh
what does this comment mean koi uh which
my favorite part of editing live stream
jjk is confused by what the person's
saying it makes for great live stream
content JJ and you're just like what are
they talking about uh JJ just kidding
what is a jjk uh Jessica Jones Kalel no
Jayden I don't even know what shows have
those letters I have no idea is is it
maybe a spelling error I don't even know
what other
I can't think of a show we reacted to
that had a jjk in it what's yeah what's
this oh Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
is that a thing there could be it do you
watch season one no oh well that's a
weird thing to start with season two uh
what does it matter all right John do
you not follow James Gunn I would like
to be I think sometimes they call you
John and sometimes they call me Jonah oh
you're John yeah it is Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
okay no I haven't seen it but appreciate
you the superset for you requesting that
we watch but maybe one day one day
uh Collide oh it's a 20. oh it's coming
no none of these are for the 25s now I
wasn't gonna switch it to 20. You're
Gonna save it for 20. okay oh
oh
yeah yeah I hadn't heard that one yet I
like that one I like that one that's
great yeah
what's that from
Deadpool Deadpool one what do you think
of Jensen Ackles as Batman
I mean we just dove into it quite a bit
actually uh I think he's perfect I think
his voice is like the actually the my
only negative about this one that's
trying to find the negative then yeah
is this voice is so good as Jensen
Ackles that I can't imagine sounding any
different is Bruce Wayne to Batman do
you know what I mean like when Jensen
Ackles talks it sounds like Batman Well
normally because I I've seen a lot of
behind the scenes with him and then I
watch him on Supernatural and I'm
Supernatural he tends to talk in a lower
register like intentionally but it's
true it's not that you know what I mean
however you know they have the thing for
the Batman now where they like do the
modulated it's just funny when I'm
watching it doesn't change his voice the
animated movies his Batman and his Bruce
Wayne are the same because his voice is
so awesome yeah like that's my only
negative is like he just sounds like
Batman always so I'd be like all right
guys Batman Bruce Wayne but uh but
Michael Keaton never changes his voice
no but that we were more forgiving at
89. yeah and then uh you know Christian
Bale had the conscious effort to be like
he needs to change his voice Batman I
was like what the [__] is he like that
does it make sense to me but people got
real mad but I think Jensen Ackles I
mean he's a guy that goes to every con
that he can he's a guy that loves the
fandom and I think that if you're
getting into a superhero now you have to
be your parents doesn't change his voice
he's just like our Whispers yeah yeah
yeah it works for me I'm cool with it
but Jensen that's what I'm saying the
Gen Cycles Batman voice is is always
it's like permanent he just is Robert
Pattinson's I guess I need to re-watch
it what was I saying pretty much it's
pretty similar oh I was saying uh in
fandom now I think you have to commit to
it being a lifestyle I don't think you
can join superhero movies right now
without it being like you are committing
to the con life so I feel like Jensen
Ackles is the best bet for Batman
because he's like already in it
this is a question that's been on my
mind no one's really talking about it uh
Mr E.T thank you for the Super Chat is
cable going to be in Deadpool 3. I don't
think so you don't think so don't think
so
I think with this movie dealing probably
with the ramifications of all the time
travel shenanigans that he does in
Deadpool Cameo but I don't think he's
gonna be a major part if if he's in it
it's a cameo he was so good I mean
Brolin's great and he looked so good as
cable too yeah it was great that's also
a concert I want to let the man eat his
you know Wheaties like I feel like he
had to get so jacked for cable again and
he's like 60 something so what I'm just
I'm not paying millions of dollars it's
still physically but I would love that
uh but I don't think is it confirmed
he's gonna be in there that no it's wait
is it no he's not it's confirmed or no
it's confirmed he is yeah
Collide Collide what have you heard
speed it up call bro we only have a 30
second delay here on the live stream
it'll get there when you get here but uh
he won't be yeah I don't think he would
be because I feel like it's going to be
so much going on
oh no Domino either I love zazzy yeah
that one bummed me out too because she
was such a highlight yeah same I really
like her stunt sequences about like uh
not in a magic but luck yeah so great
bye Peter
all right he's just here all right
Marcus Santos
someone said you look like Walter White
and this is what I actually thought koi
looking like Jesse Pinkman [__] right
yeah [__] Comics also Superman versus
the elite is a good watch for another
movie you guys should check out don't
worry there there's plenty there's a
company they're coming once I started
them on this journey I knew I knew these
would be off to the right keep watching
and liking and commenting on them so we
keep doing them though uh I'm glad so
many people have been enthusiastic about
it jungus learn about some stuff
in that Medium to see the medium yeah
it's awesome uh I appreciate the Jesse
Pinkman love because that's one of my
favorite characters in all of TV
did you see do you watch It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia yes have you seen
the latest season no is Aaron Paul in it
the latest episode that aired or second
to latest episode uh has both Brian
Cranston and Aaron Paul oh are they like
selling tequila
oh that's so good uh if you guys don't
know and you follow this channel you
should watch uh season one I've always
sunny for a certain Cameo from a reject
because it blew my mind yeah what is he
like 40. uh when I was watching that and
you were like you when you popped up I
was actually incredulous like I had a
moment of life because I didn't know and
I feel like I know a lot of my friends
when they work at things so I remember
like sending you a photo and you and I
weren't nearly as close yet I was like
bro are you in Always Sunny like as a as
a Young Man uh so yeah Greg's not always
sending season one goddamn right
Nathan palafia
Batman is solo the dragon is the best
recent DC animated I feel like this live
you guys are saving all your goods all
the good stuff for here yes thought this
was gonna be the live action uh is the
best recent DC animated actually doesn't
sideline and respects DC Comic best
martial artists as well uh that is one I
actually have not seen myself don't
worry I'll pull up a third year going no
I'm okay
you're gonna react with three people
but yeah I'm excited for that one I love
that they're still ongoing and I hear
they've kept up at quality wise yeah I
am
Alexander hunt we got a 15. we got a 15.
I love these this is
oh yeah first off you guys are
distracted by the own joke
uh I do have a spec pilot script a spec
pilot I do have a spec script in mind of
what I would do for my character return
It's Always Sunny do you really dude I
feel like it was just so funny to fix
this about this one little line I had
and make a whole episode of
anyways one of my bucket list goals to
interview and if I ever get in front of
him be like hey I know a guy that was on
I actually have a script great It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia I'll tell
you it after dude we gotta get it yeah
I'll tell you it later and it's one that
I'm like I'm surprised they haven't done
it and I think it would be such a good
episode it might happen guys uh first
off you guys are amazing thank you we
know we don't need to be reminded
but we can be but it feels good to be
told also how Keen are you for the boys
season four very keen I'm Daphne
thinking about the whole thing about it
man nicely done nice accident because
because the boys is a consistent
form of quality nuanced entertainment
and Eric Kripke was like we are not
putting everything on pause right now
they're not going to air it until the
registry's over which I respect they
can't even do like ADR or any any
reasons they said they can't do any of
that because of the writer strike yeah I
feel like I also feel like even if they
were done which I think they are they'd
he respects writers yeah kripke's like
he uh organized he's a writer he's a
writer but he also organized like a
whole um March outside of Sony and like
had like fans come meet like the cast
and stuff like he's so for the people
that he's willing to like rally his
people publicly which is really a great
showing of strings from a showrunner I'm
really impressed
um I personally am very excited because
um I've I've gotten closer to a couple
cast members in the show and they think
it's the best season yet and they have
no reason to off the Record say that um
and I also think that we as a culture
are more and more accepting of the
insanity of the boys right so I love
that like the show can get bigger and it
actually makes sense to uh also the
world's gotten more messed up since the
show started airing so I feel like it's
the commentary of what the show is only
works better are you excited for the
spin-off of the boys uh
casually excited I I think that
everything they've done so far in
Universe has been great I just don't
know what a younger one looks like so
once I see a trailer or something that
gives some story I'll be more excited
but right now I'm just cautious I think
they should have made some type of crap
titles just so people knew it was
connected to the boys like the boys gen
V instead of just gin V or whatever it
is yeah I think they're showing stuff a
Comic-Con they should say like gen V the
boys right yeah I think they're showing
stuff a Comic Con I'm not 100 but I
that's when I'm gonna get excited or not
Peter you're starting to annoy some
people my friend I'm gonna uh what what
are they doing they keep leaving these
kind of comments and it's pissing me off
it's getting me to rage can I go to
superchat before I don't understand what
that means uh let's see here Trenton
rustuli restul
do you think we would get multiple
Deadpool so do you think he is like
America Chavez it's a great question uh
I do not think of Deadpool as a Nexus
being but I think it'd be a really great
way to introduce the Deadpool core I
think be a great way to show gwenpool I
think it'd be a great way to have
multiple types of Deadpool so personally
I hope they acknowledge Nexus beings and
make fun of the idea that Benedict
Cumberbatch was all the doctors change
because it makes no sense so in this
movie I think making fun of things is
the way to solve a lot of the Canon
problems of the MCU so I think there
will be multiple Deadpools too make fun
of the singular Benedict Cumberbatch
because Wanda is a Nexus being not
everyone is and it doesn't make sense
the way they're half making rules so I
think there will be multiple Deadpools I
would also see like someone in the chat
asked earlier who other uh actors as
Deadpool it'd be really fun to see like
Sean William Scott as a Deadpool or like
uh Rob mcelinney be a funny Deadpool in
their friends things like that would be
great come on man there's one big one
Nolan North Jesus Christ come on why
have you not pulled this one who you got
starts with a D
anny DeVito
you're close not not in person just the
name uh uh done
you wrote the best animated Deadpool of
all time the script that Donald Glover
wrote the morning the show was canceled
is one of the most accurate Deadpool
representations of all time he literally
wrote a four-page script about the
cancellation of the show which
referenced that day's news showing that
he wrote it that day and it was funnier
than most anything I've ever read Donald
Glover for Deadpool how cool would that
be oh he never lose my mind he never
gets to play the actual rules so he's
just a cast of Cameo to make up for
Donald Glover always the brightest like
he's just right there have you seen an
ad for the uh there was like a
simulation ad that had uh Donald Glover
as Prowler with all the Spider-Man and
he's carrying the pizza like in
community that's cool yeah it's like
just a random TV yet TJ Perry friend
from Saint Charles the school we went to
he's a 10 TJ
super question that's probably the best
sounding it's so good because I love the
Distortion you did yes yes
yes thank you
I hear you're confident I accept it I
hear Ryan Reynolds next project is
acquiring stake in real rejects nicely
done after wrexham mobile and Aviation
gin what can we expect oh my God I would
love for Ryan Reynolds to uh buy some
stock with uh the real rejects this is
publicly traded it's a publicly traded
company they got on my Vanguard app it's
going it's going terrible but I feel
like if Ryan Reynolds invested in it
suddenly there might be some actual
interest to invest in it you know what I
mean someone asked earlier who uh who's
my dream uh Ryan Reynolds I've never
interviewed
um I actually have said like you've
interviewed everyone no someone asked
you're just like I've actually never out
of interviewed Ryan roads Ryan Reynolds
is part of the reason I'm a host uh
because of Deadpool so like the fact
that we haven't gotten to talk about
Deadpool is insane to me so Ryan
Reynolds is like high on the bucket list
because like I can't even imagine so uh
mint mobile I think was huge for him I
think that maybe he'll run a studio one
day maximum effort is I think the mo
most impressive
PR is so hard and no one's ever uh ahead
of the curve quite like Ryan Reynolds is
whilst he's also an entrepreneur and
businessman and actor so what he's able
to do with all these things I'd love to
see him run a studio like a small Indie
Studio he's got a hot wife and he's got
a hot wife yeah and bring back comedy
man I'd love to see an indie student
imagine a24 for comedy yeah imagine some
like classic R-rated comedies returning
because of an a24 for for laws it's
called Joyride I'm excited to watch it
um it's tone bro
no in the live stream loves them
they kind of like them I love them it's
not deafening this video that's
something first off first off first off
first off do you uh I just want to say
I've been watching it for almost 10
years at this point Greg
wow we've been around for like 10 years
publicly traded company publicly traded
company
I'm so happy you get all this stuff from
where you began yeah
working in my room but we've got a
Comic-Con panel but I want to hear koi's
secret Invasion predictions well I'm
glad we have been able to uh be here I I
am very appreciative of the fact that
this started off as a little quaint
journey and now I get to make my living
doing this and
also get a
it's crazy when you have like selling
koi will not reveal the number but I was
telling koi like I just had to pay like
a bunch of you know employees number I
gave him the number and I was like yes
and then to me I was like it's kind of
crazy I do this now yeah after I told
you that and I got to be like Duke just
cut it I hope you hear the positive it's
like and I know you were giving negative
news but I hope you hear the positive
yeah it's nuts did you get like give
people work yeah and like honestly I've
been doing this I've been doing this 10
years as of February like hosting uh and
this is real rejects I've been here
since I've been 10 years hosting we only
just started airing he really did pretty
much trying to get it working and
flowing before we put out a video it's
really processing yeah the haircuts to
show time proof of time uh no I uh I've
been doing this 10 years and I can
comfortably say my favorite place to
work is real rejects yeah oh dude
comfortably like and you can clip this
out and show it to every other network I
work for do it but we're the least
professional no it's the place that
cares the most about like what my
opinion opinion actually is like you let
me be honest you let me actually share
my opinion you're not trying to like
stifle any of it and like koi's comic
corner is the most authentic thing that
is me and something else we're cooking
up is what I want to be doing with you
guys and we're we're going in the
direction of everything I've wanted to
build but it's in a place that's both
benefiting you and me I never feel
guilty and I never feel like it's
hurting the brand to let me be fully me
and I look forward to it like it's not a
thing that that like I'm like oh work
I'm like man I get to do what I love to
do but in an environment that's
supportive and comforting and also like
you are a good boss oh
don't ever call me a boss it felt weird
never say felt weird I hated it I hated
it immediately I did not like it never
let someone's call me that's my ball
it is so uncomfortable where your
goddamn secret evasion prediction score
that's weird predictions
[Music]
just now I feel weird about it uh so I
think secret invasion is gonna have Don
Cheadle um as a double-blind I think
he's not a squirrel I think it's a
mislead I think that they want us to
think he's a scroll because the nick uh
and because of a few other details
they've given I think he's not but he
might be but I'm going 90 not a scroll
uh I think we reveal that one of the
Avengers is a scroll by the end of it uh
and I think that
um
one more one more prediction I think
that okay you're getting censored left
and right but all these all these other
companies uh and I think that Ben
Mendelson dies
um I want to go on Christian harlock's
Channel and new rock stars and be like
so you censor koi here huh
that's what I got from this compliment
he paid the real reason yeah this is all
about again making other people look bad
not about no I mean new rockstars is
really fun and and working with
Christians really fun but I definitely
like the the Christian harloff audience
is a very different audience than the
real racix audience like reject nation
is much more like the people I I want to
deal with
um so it's just it's just different
thank you oh 20.
everyone
oh
I'm trying to yours so good so good
please watch the long Halloween Jensen
is perfect oh I wonder if someone just
watched the long Halloween perhaps part
one part one perhaps to air uh not this
Sunday but next Sunday perhaps I was
saying that I've recently enjoyed Jensen
Nichols as Batman for a reason yeah
serious perhaps
I'll flick and reel it up buddy what up
what are the chances we meet the bat fam
and the Brave and the Bold more than
just Damien okay so after we get to this
wave of awesome supers I want to make
sure we talk about some Superman Legacy
stuff okay video did well it was such a
background we're gonna be a little
behind the scenes on that push it back
and forth whether or not to do it it was
so funny yeah could you describe it
we're gonna I want to say also next time
I wanna next time there's breaking news
I want to just uh if you're around in
the area I'm just like we're just gonna
do a live I want to see how that goes oh
I want to just like do you want to tell
the people have that 40 minutes away
because it's really funny to me yeah
it's really funny
um flicking real uh what are the chances
of we will when we talk about it what
are the chances we meet the bat fam and
the Brave and the Bold I think that's
the goal right I think the goal is yeah
he said he he specifically signed a bat
family which got me so Jazz yeah I have
been one like I had my own
Batman franchise in mind
oh
I like that
censored live
this would be such a great franchise
title I like that a lot and it's a good
umbrella but I wanted to I'll give a
little spoiler I wanted to start it off
um at the death of Jason Todd I wanted
that to be the opening scene I like that
of it and then I had like a Ted movie
thing where it would end with an Arkham
Asylum oh that's fun yeah get some actor
who's gonna willing to commit like Hugh
Jackman for 10 years yeah
um but yeah but the idea but the idea is
to get the bat family involved yeah the
time and then and my Arkham Asylum would
have
um the bat family there instead of just
Batman alone so I like that a lot yeah
so you got a whole whole Shenanigans but
anyway but yeah that's why I'm I'm super
excited about uh the bad family coming
in and yeah I feel like the focus will
be on Damien and Bruce but I think we'll
at least get
um alluding to or thanks for being here
Lego gamer at least get alluding to or I
don't know if we'll get like a whole
like freaking Ensemble or maybe he opens
up an email and then there's this emails
of a bunch of video footage of all them
showing it's just a text he's got a
family chat yeah uh I think we get I
feel like right he just opens it and
there's like Barbara Gordon
I think honestly the way they're doing
it is like the reason they're keeping
the Batman is that's gonna be the
grounded one and then all the people I
personally like a grounded Batman but
every single time I mention that I get
like 30 people being like I'm so sick of
Batman being grounded and gritty and
real people want this like ridiculous
Supernatural over the top like
you can't do
Lazarus Pit without some type of hiding
Batman story that's why it's gonna be
great yeah you can't do it so yeah every
day people are are tweeting like the one
I saw today which I really was judgment
to love and said like they need to be
more creative I think a grounded
Batman's pretty creative you had to be
creative to make that Universe work
anyway the bat chat the batch yes but I
think that family allows for like a
giant um a bit of heightened reality
where you can tell all the stories that
wouldn't work like you can do a Solomon
Grundy you can do a Killer Croc that
feels plausible you can do all those
things and then you save all the
grounded characters for Matt Reeves like
I think having both is literally your
cake and eat it too bad family is the
way to make it big and heightened it's
coming yeah because you know he's
mattress has talked about maybe like
those rumors are like Clayface is gonna
be a Batman too I think it's a great
commentary in AI though and uh yeah
that's what I mean like whatever it's
going to be is not gonna it can't
possibly I mean unless man Rose manages
to pull something [__] if anyone
wants a miracle out of his ass uh yeah I
mean we know that Matt Reeves can do
super like he did Cloverfield he doesn't
let me in uh the planet the ace movies
he's done things that are certainly not
just based in reality right yeah so sure
he can do it but I imagine whatever
Clayface interpretation if if he is if
it is Clay his or even if it was Mr
Freeze it's not going to be the Comic
version right whereas this side of the
universe can be more comic accurate yeah
I totally agree and I think Dick Grayson
is the most overdue character in DC I
think Nightwing's coming and I think
it'll be a fully fleshed out nightwinger
yeah that's like I think we get that's
been my dream or my dream origin this
thing to write would have been my
scarecrow movie and my Nightwing movie
but I feel like the Nightwing movie
would I'd have to be like oh what's
going on in your [__] Universe right
it was about scarecrow I'm like let me
just do an elsewhere let me play yeah uh
vedem carnate
thank you for the Super Chat what are
your most Niche Superman Easter eggs or
World building aspects do you want in
Superman Legacy boom a side note really
love Deadpool's new suit oh that's a
great question Superman Easter eggs is
there a particular Superman Easter egg
koi that you would love to see in
Superman Legacy I would personally love
to see Lana Lang which isn't really an
Easter egg but I feel like the movies
have never really done Lana Lang Justice
I've always loved the idea that Lana
Lang was like his love before Lois Lane
I was loved like the Smallville
relationship and Kristen crewick has one
like taught me love uh Kristen krupik is
such a a force in Smallville I'd love to
see a character like that in from his
past so it's not really an Easter egg
but I really feel like the the longevity
of Superman is important I feel like
when we meet Superman in modern movies
he's like it's right now but I I feel
like the legacy of the character is is
as important as anything else uh I'd
love to see crypto
I think crypto is a wonderful character
that I've never seen
um Easter eggs Easter eggs Easter eggs
can I tell you what uh what do you got
my opening scene to be oh please oh my
openings seem to be
uh David uh what's his name sweaty balls
David porn sweat yeah
that's why he needs the boxer briefs
what a weird name of course what is that
chordsman is that really how you
pronounce it yeah like corn sweat
I don't I don't make names
um anyway my name is Coley I want the
opening of him he's fighting he's
fighting someone in Metropolis and all
of a sudden
things start colliding in the sky
and then he turns looks over and he sees
the finale of the two flashes fighting
and then he looks to his right and he
sees Christopher Reeves Superman and
then to his left he sees Nick cage
fighting a spider and he's like what the
hell is going on don't do this don't do
this it never happened as I want to see
from the perspective of what it was like
for those Supermen to watch this and
they'd be like what the hell is
happening right now so someone should
acknowledge this I'm gonna slowly turn
around and then it just ends and he's
like okay
I guess that's done that was some sort
of crisis on Infinite Arts uh I want
Superman to open uh in the Daily Planet
and I want it to open with uh Clark Kent
and Lois Lane and Jimmy Olsen like in a
moment of actual conversation and then
he takes off and then yeah I want the
opening film uh the opening of the film
to be them as people and then him
busting it open his shirt with the
Superman logo and then that's the
opening credits like I think this moment
is so iconic and it hasn't been quite
like reused in a while in the right way
and I really think Jimmy Olsen being in
the opening is is kind of vital because
Clark Kent is is a character we need
more of you know what I'm looking
forward to most about Superman Legacy
that I think it ha that just hasn't been
done yet even I would even say in the
Christopher Reeves one
because it just feels like New York City
there
um is making Metropolis that's one thing
James talked about on the on the Michael
Roosevelt podcast was to how their each
City can feel like its own world and we
haven't seen something where like the
Superman animated series really makes
Metropolis feel like it doesn't just
feel like New York City you know yeah
and I feel like that's what James Gunn
is really going to hone in on doing is
making Metropolis Stand Out be
distinguish itself from just look it
looks like Chicago or something right
right I feel like we're really gonna get
Metropolis brought to life inside I
totally agree apparently it's corin's
wet and it's his birthday oh well happy
birthday sweaty buff I agree though
Gotham and Metropolis should feel
different and right now like I feel like
Metropolis should be slightly futuristic
I always feel like Metropolis is a
little bit ahead of us yeah and I don't
think I've felt that way about
Metropolis in a while and that's why I
referenced the the ministers in the 90s
because I thought that was a perfect uh
that was perfect kind of a perfect blend
of it yeah
um Panthers rule 95 police Channing
Tatum Gambit in Deadpool 3. yes that is
a and again Channing Tatum what else did
he appear in that uh rom-com God damn it
Ryan Reynolds he appeared in bullet
train which has cameos for both of them
Ryan Reynolds and Channing Tatum came in
bullet train and uh
what else
Andy's in free
directed by Sean Levy Levy Levy
sweaty balls directed by Sean Sean
sweaty John's sweaty balls directed
bullet train and no he didn't freak out
uh yeah I I want this very bad I also
feel like uh when you look at that image
of everyone at the Comic-Con Hall age
stage like Channing Tatum's in the front
and he never got to play game but he's
like wearing a Gambit t-shirt and it
haunts me because I know a lot of people
didn't want him as Gambit but his
passion for it was so contagious I
really like I want him to have that I
feel like Channing Tatum and and Josh
Hartnett are two actors who started off
not good
and then became great actors eventually
I think they're both great yeah yeah
ironically both I mean uh Joshua and
bazama Superman he turned it down was he
yeah it's turned out I think both Josh
Hartnett and and Channing Tatum have
that interesting career trajectory we
were like they're really good looking
they're not the greatest actors but man
they're pretty and then they became like
really great actors their trajectories
are both crazy because Josh Hartnett
came out of nowhere as like I'm a
leading man and then we put him in
everything yeah and then Channing
Tatum's like I can dance so like you
should act two uh they're both great but
no I think Channing Tatum and Deadpool
three that to me would make me so happy
like that that would be for me for I I
know how much the Nick Cage Superman
Cameo meant yeah I feel like I would
really have that feeling for Channing
Tatum showing up as Gambit I don't want
him in the head thing like the mask
that's like the weird side like a Jim
Lee Gambit I want him to be like the
trench coat hey pretty
how does he say in the X-Men show pretty
pretty oh petite petite yeah I want him
to say Manco or my heart yeah man
I want a sugar from Rogue too I wonder
who's gonna play Rogue
dead shot thank you dead shot Rogue
right
because I don't think I had a pack when
and Channing Tatum is the same pairing
I'd have a different Rogue dude Rebel
Wilson what do you guys think of Blade
potentially being R-rated also Greg
since a couple shows came out can we get
some MK reactions if you can please
yeah those uh Mortal Kombat videos are
all limited ads for and while over here
who get away with not getting the
limited apps but I was doing uh going
through the video manager like these are
all yellow dollars
um we're just one of those channels that
gets hit with that what do you guys
think of Blade being potentially being
R-rated I mean we've talked about this
quite a bit uh I think it's the smart
move yeah I know some people are saying
that they can get away with it being
PG-13 can you get away with it
sure yeah you can do it of course you
can do a PG-13 version is will that make
it the best it can be I don't think so
at all especially after
iconic R-rated Blade movies it seems
kind of weird to go PG-13 all of a
sudden I I say blade is the thing that
started the MCU and it's because it was
so good that it didn't lean on the comic
characters a lot of people didn't know
blade was a comic character when they
saw the movie they were just like Wesley
Snipes awesome so I think that like
those movies are historic and we should
replicate the R-rated intensity not try
to tone it down and I think when
Deadpool does gangbusters we're gonna
get a lot more R-rated Marvel I think
we're already playing in that world with
some of the violence and secret Invasion
like the hands like we're already
dabbling and Deadpool's on Disney plus
so go are rated like the the mcu's been
around 15 years people that were three
when that started are adults let it be
an adult thing as well as a young thing
so I I think already blade is needed I
mean to me especially blade lives matter
uh because
when you hear that they're bringing
blade into the MCU sure it's not Wesley
Snipes commercial Ali but everyone who
heard about that most people were like
aware of the Blade movies already you
know what I mean yeah and everyone knows
those are rated R films and you think of
the like the most
I think the most iconic moment out of
the Blade movies is the first 10 minutes
of his blood the whole franchise the
first 10 minutes is the most iconic part
of the whole move of of all those films
and and blood makes things R-rated it
does unfortunately vampires drink blood
weirdly it does yes uh so I I think it I
would love if it was R-rated personally
they can push the lines it can push the
boundaries but I feel like you need the
gore I think you do I think Craven's
gonna be an interesting I think you need
I think you need more R-rated than
Daredevil born again I agree and also go
see Craven if you want R-rated comic
movies I know it's gonna upset you but I
I'm excited I would love if Craven's
actually Goods that way people will go
we should do more rated movies yeah I'm
hoping koi please
oh
do you think Deadpool oh and it's a
Deadpool question yes thank you Troy
um do you think in Deadpool 3 Wade
somehow time jumps into the universe
of Daredevil or the university Elektra
movie
that's probably okay that's a good
question actually yeah that's probably
one thing I think it'd be a little bit
more akin to what he um did at the end
of dead uh at the end of the movie he's
got a Time Turner like yeah he's hopping
into the movie he hops into like X-Men
Origins Wolverine yeah I feel like
that's a little bit more of what he
would do I think it'd be a little bit
more exciting but he literally kills him
his elf like he kills Ryan Reynolds is
he electro movie fun I've never seen it
uh there's a great sequence on uh seesaw
I liked
I don't remember it at all I literally
the one scene I thought was from Elektra
is gone yeah I don't know I actually
don't remember it
I know there's a cool size stuff
like a ribbon scene maybe she plays like
with color guard but speaking of Elektra
I really hope they carry over the
election who played Elektra in in the
Daredevil show she was in an insanely I
don't remember her oh God man but I was
close I would love uh I would love the
time Turner element to be how he gets
around I also think he's probably gonna
be investigated by the TVA for what
Deadpool 2 ends with right I think
they're like oh my God it's a it's an
event and then like you know they're
trying to stop him and that's what
accidentally ends the Universe I think
Deadpool accidentally kills the fox
Universe
um what are the chances that Deadpool
jumps to the universe with Thomas Jane's
Punisher just for the hell of it well
speaking of which I'll let you guys know
right now Tara and John have never seen
The Punisher and we have a reaction for
theirs coming up next week the Thomas
Jane Punisher yeah oh I'm so jealous
so slept on
um the short film too the dirty oh Dirty
Laundry amazing like up there with John
bernthals yeah yeah that's what uh John
Bernthal said he was in fact oh yeah he
said like he took a lot of inspiration
from that one and it shows I think in
his performance I I think that would be
so cool so if they cut Thomas James but
they should do it all they should
literally wrap up like all the all the
fox universe that's the way to
acknowledge it and create a transition
all of it and I feel like that's
probably the main element where Kevin
feige would have
um some input as to how to handle
specifically that it also allows the
fresh cut for the MCU like for X-Men
like you get new X-Men because the old
ones are gone and they had to wait a
certain amount of years to use those
characters so like do it right end it
well uh also didn't mean to go to your
channel um I meant to highlight your
comment and now you're just on screen a
lot it's just a quiz
just a big Fanny uh uh well I was gonna
say Thomas Jane and Chris Evans in the
same movie if Chris Evans is in Deadpool
would be a vegan uh Bros Cameo from
Scott Pilgrim that's one of my favorite
cameos of either of them yeah remember
they were the vegan Twins and it's got
pilgrims yeah yeah I would love that
all right where are we at where are we
at Brody cubes best Wolverine Comic I'm
a big fan of the Frank Miller miniseries
I'm also a big fan of fan of uh agent of
shield where he's like an assassin
that's been taken over uh the current
Wolverine run right now is pretty strong
uh because he's like actually feral and
then like uh rough again it's written by
Benjamin Percy who's also reading the
Ghost Rider run right now a lot of good
Wolverine stuff but uh some highlights
of those
you were taking way too long I was so
sorry quickly I meant to highlight her
because she put on Lodi young played uh
oh yeah fighter that's her name Elektra
um
I love your mama too
great name goddess of 20.
top five video games you all are excited
for Spider-Man 2 Spider-Man 2 uh Mortal
Kombat one looks fire would you ever
make a real Ridge X gaming channel in
the future Greg well man uh one of these
there's uh I don't want to talk about
this other thing that I'm working on
um but yeah it's cool what I'm working
on love you guys don't ever stop making
great videos
a gaming channel I don't know
um there I want to figure out how to
properly do a gaming like I think
Spider-Man 2 would be really fun to
stream here uh there's some games that I
think would be great to stream here I'd
love that but the thing is I'm not like
like I I understand that when we're
watching a movie or a show here a big
part of it is
like what I always tell people
especially if they're like new here is
whatever you're feeling internally let
it out like that's one of the reasons I
love doing reactions is
in real prior to this doing the channel
uh I was a I was a very very
internalized quiet
um almost repressed type of
responder when it comes to say like I'm
a fight like an early EMT responder a
late responder not a first responder
like I had here's a fact about me is
when I was really really young there was
this channel called the monster channel
on and we had cable for one month I'll
never forget that we had cable for one
month and there's a moss shot 24 hours a
day horror movies uncensored and I must
it was definitely before I was even a
teenager and I did this weird thing
where I would go
you are not going to look away no matter
how gory it is and you are going to you
you will not flinch any like you just I
just wouldn't allow myself to do it
and if I was ever in a crowd if people
were like doing Muse if it was a concert
or whatever or whatever it might be I
would never express how I'm thinking or
feeling internally I would never really
I was very restrained to myself
um and this allowed me the opportunity
to express myself of what was going and
it became like a process of discovery of
letting that out so I I'm really
grateful it's allowed me to be more in
touch with my emotions do what I do here
and knowing like in order for these
videos to be great I got to get more
comfortable expressing my emotions and
so yeah like that what I always tell
people when they're here is like show
what you're feeling and internally like
let out we need some commentary because
we need you to cut away too sure so like
let your thoughts out uh let your
thoughts out and let your let your
feelings out like that's a big part of
of what we do I'm bringing this all up
to say that when I game
I am not that way like let's say this
Biofreeze was a controller when I game I
am just
I'm so [__] serious
yeah that's the only time you hear me is
when I'm like [__] can't [__] beat
this like I'm just pissed off at the
camera that's the only time you hear me
talk other than that I'm just really
quiet I would be afraid I don't know how
to talk properly yeah unless I'm doing
like a versing game and I'm like talking
[__] to the person yeah that's the only
time I know how to do it but if I'm
playing like a story mode I am just like
this is personal development time this
is strategy this is for me I'm building
my brain I'm really thinking I'm in my
head yeah and I feel like if you just
become this whole other it's kind of a
meditative experience for me when I'm
gaming like it's the only thing I'm
thinking about yeah and and if so then I
I feel like it will rob me from that
feeling
of when I am playing the games with a
cam reported at me yeah but it's
Spider-Man so I'm like but it's
Spiderman
that's the only one I think I could do
because I feel like I had to offer some
insights whereas I'm not good at gaming
and I like you can't be bad at watching
movies so I feel like the comments would
judge my inability of the game right
right so that's that's a thing uh and
they did announce Last of Us three so
I'm really I'm really looking forward to
that my my variety of games has become a
lot more narrow I don't have a big
variety because they just don't have as
much yes exactly I just don't have that
much time and and as I know me it's like
if I started I'm really going to want to
complete it and if I don't it's going to
really bug me and then I make a lot of
excuses then I'll work on the things I
really got to work on because I'm like
oh get around to writing this thing but
but I think she's off my mind first but
let me just commit like several hours
yeah it happens a lot I make that choice
it's one of my I could teach a class on
how to procrastinate uh Collide Anna De
armas as Wonder Woman
cliche but a good cliche I like it I'd
like it she's my Zatanna because I think
uh anadarmus is a little on the short
side and one woman's like statue-ask and
Tall uh I know a good Rogue should be a
great Rogue should be a good Rogue I
want annadarmus's Rogue more even than
Zatanna in this moment uh but yeah she's
she's just to me like Wonder Woman's
like so statuesque and I know you can
shoot creatively like Tom Cruise is
shorter than me but at the same time
I think the Wolverine height thing is a
part of his character and I think the
height of Wonder Woman's part of her
character so I I would want someone
taller yeah yeah
no one's talking about what if season
two anymore true oh true and that's
supposed to be all about phase four
which has ended unceremoniously quiet
koi we got a 25.
I'm touching myself
first off
let's say you guys are the best
thank you for everything they're from
the south Dance For Life what is the
most anticipated film of 2023. I've
already seen them uh for the rest of
2023 mine actually my number one is not
out yet what's yours the Killer
the David Fincher yeah it's my most
anticipated of the year
him returning to his roots I there's no
director like Fincher for me for
excitement in the theater uh Nolan's
close and that's why Oppenheimer was my
number three of the year but um
comfortably the killer I wish I was more
pretentious
um it's easy because I
wish I was more pretentious because I
could not finish whatever that Gary oh
it's so rough I love future and I just
couldn't get into it and I want
Adventure movie again I was like an hour
in and I'm like you know what not for me
I think I'm turning this off I finished
it but I wasn't happy I like I'm just
not that guy that was that was I had
such a heart I'm like I know that's a
movie
and like I just don't get it man and and
like my wife Olivia like her favorite
kind of films are are old school movies
yeah like I'm talking really old movies
like black and white Humphrey bows
that's that is her name like her
favorite movie of all times gone with
the win I know it's not black and white
but like cheap that's always the ones
it's her picks that's what she wants to
put on is is something that the talkies
you know um and so I thought perfect
this is great a perfect marriage sure I
love Fincher this is like the citizen
game whatever thingy it's in black and
white let's we were both like this is
not driving
that makes me feel a lot better actually
because I was afraid I'm afraid to say I
don't like it I'm glad that is the only
Fincher movie I just could not do yeah
but other than that I like I even like
alien three he's my favorite director
and I I am doing a Michael Fassbender
Tilda Swinton based off a French comic
movie yeah very excited it's my number
one anticipate of the year did not know
it's a French conference movie okay cool
uh Dance For Less sorry yes we answered
your question we did we did did you guys
read the plot leak for the Marvels no we
did not because the movie's probably
like way too short as it is
and I'm excited for they're probably
going to feel rushed I don't I don't
like spoilers I know that's YouTube
anti-youtube culture but it's not my
dream
uh we obviously stopped around this
Spider-Man time as I think in the
Spider-Man time A lot of it was like you
know we were all just like itching for
some [__] and like that was part of the
fun of it is like what's what's going to
come true you know and like because the
leaks were just not remember the number
two remember the days of Spider-Man no
way home but what a crazy era like the
leaks were just so
out of this world and most of them were
not true and it became like a fun little
game well yeah because most of them
weren't true but I'll never ever
spoiled by Toby's dick yeah then it
became a little too like too true oh now
yeah now I know this now it's now it's
yeah I'm not picking spoilers
um yeah like it did it did get to a
point where like obviously it totally
ruined the experience for some people
but for me it did it I I it was part of
the fun and the journey and then we were
gonna kind of do the same thing for
Doctor Strange leading I'm glad we did
it yeah but yeah we there was a point
where we were going to kind of do the
same for Doctor Strange
um but then uh we stopped I also hate
that there's so much internet culture
like oh it's just spoilers who cares
well clearly the person that says they
don't like spoilers and you can't unknow
something so like there's this entire
culture that enjoys ruining other
people's experiences that should die
slowly yeah yeah yeah so we um we
definitely it's been um it's been a
minute since I've even covered like a
plot leak like a long time perspective
now that we've said there's gonna be so
much [__] in the crap yeah everyone
starts anyone spoiling stuff I wish you
guys
um Chris Mars hey thank you for the
stream Lab the take less phase please
continue to pause the Marvel outlook on
this channel we're trying we try
we try unless it really we haven't seen
Bird Box Barcelona I'm Gonna Keep I'm
really back and forth on whether or not
I'm gonna react to it or not I saw in
the chat and I totally agree uh my big
fan cast for gwenpool is Blake Lively I
think that'd be genius my other Fan cast
for gwenpool is Emma Stone because it'd
be a fun way to tie in uh Gwen Stacy
from Spider-Man and bring that all
together so I think Emma Stone and Blake
Lively would be fun gwenbos all right
Chris Mars eight thank you for the ten
here we go
make one for stream oh
are there any art projects outside of
real rejects that you're working on you
can talk about a little
um there's one within real rejects we
can talk about
I think do you want anyone talk about it
you can talk about a little I guess
there's a variation we shot an episode
already
of a thing say whatever you want to say
and I'll I'll get a little bit and um it
was a long work in progress like a whole
crew involved
and then a lot of time on my end has
been a lot of a lot of some stuff with
pre-production like literally we're
actually using this kind of terminology
we have to because of the amount of
people involved yeah
and uh is a segment starring koi
and
um it involves outside Talent so we were
going to start promoting it proper
but
we can't quite we made an announce that
I wonder con about it but we can't
really do anything right now because
it's the one thing at real rejects that
is certainly affected by the writer
strike and the sex because with the
other Talent involved that we were it
was getting to some like cool names yeah
um I don't want to like over to sell the
the the come and really watching my
words here I don't want to oversell the
Quality caliber of talent there were
some names that were pretty high up
there though and then it would be
because even when it was coming to the
rider strike they did it these people
would get uncomfortable about doing uh
uh things that I even though they were
writers
um and then of course the sack strike is
blooming and it seems like they're
really trying to prevent the sex track
from happening that's why they pushed
the data when it could happen which
could help us a lot
um but with that no one's really
committing to anything so my point with
that is there's something that has spent
when I say a long time on it I mean a
lot of money and a lot of time from
everyone yeah everyone
um and it what I feel bad about is like
we just can't do anything with what we
have right now even though we have one
complete yeah
we can't really do anything with it
until because it would be weird to just
air one and not have any others follow
up and that's hard because the one is
great and the production quality like
well I'm proud of all of it yeah
so yeah there is something and it is
coming we just don't know when or how
and there will be more of it and we
can't wait to talk about it more yeah
and we might talk about it some at
Comic-Con yeah it depends
it depends TBD all right all right here
we go here we
go all right hold on I'm gonna do some
quick name checks here okay we got Sammy
boys got two so I'm just gonna hop to
there okay okay all right
Sammy boy thank you for the stream that
my friend
okay
dead air uh do you think we get a
Harrison Ford cameos Thunderbolt rods
and secret Invasion I think the last
episode having Harrison Ford Cameo might
be amazing this was in her car and she's
accusing me of uh is that a
like an a Q-tip like an ear thing no it
looks like a
like an eyebrow thing I don't know what
that tool is I don't know what it is
I don't know
well what is that my cut is clean
uh are excited for X-Men and F4 to take
the man from the OG Avengers I think
that's very likely uh I think phase
seven eight and nine are gonna be very
uh or maybe even six seven and eight are
gonna be very X-Men Fantastic Four heavy
wait which which one are you reading I
was reading the live chat
no dead air oh my God you filming that
again with the flash podcast being an
extension of The Flash movie what is
stopping DC to make comics of Justice
League part two and three or a Cage
Superman adaptation likeness I mean
every movie had a prequel comic
um well I mean these things cost a lot
of money and no one's making money at
the box office apparently yet it's not
even effort and then we're also trying
to establish a clear continuity timeline
and and not confuse the audiences I
think it would I think ultimately it
would result in chaos and not
um and not consistency and having things
be concise and clear-cut Sammy boy is
also following up with I was watching
the Slate of Marvel movies into my
surprise before Kang Dynasty there are
five movies and only Fantastic Four
would make sense to have a king related
story as the king event uh been built to
enough
I no I mean we got Loki season two as
well and they also have uh yeah I mean
we'll have Fantastic Four but I think
there'll be other ways of implementing a
little bit of Kang here or there uh
maybe in Marvel's in some way I think
we're gonna start getting a little bit
more mentions
as we ultimately progress I think it's
inevitable they have to make Kang bigger
but also uh I think that the things that
have been built so far are multiversal
and I think that in Kang Dynasty we
might find out that things are not as
they seem and that'll be a big tie-in I
just totally realize I misread your your
comment here what is stoppy DC to make
comics I totally misread that I'm sorry
um yeah okay you know what I that would
be awesome I think Zack Snyder might
even be okay with that his movies are
look like paintings anyway these movies
look like art and I feel like and he
even released the storyboards for them
so while would it be you know the the
film itself I think if we were to get
this is the way how they continue the
Batman 89 in the comics yeah you could
do that with Justice League part two and
three and I think that that could
satisfy some type of itch for people I
would love that because it would also
get people buying Comics uh you guys
know that's always what I want people to
do and if you're such a Snyder fan
that'd be great for you to find your
comic
all right Sani had one here Sandy
what is your guys opinions on the studio
from here what are you guys opinions on
movies marketing budgets being almost
the whole budget of making the movie in
my opinion is also a factor of movies
being profitable I think what movies and
I kind of talk about this quite a bit uh
with Paul heavy spoilers on the podcast
we do is I I think it's uh almost
acidine what's happening with films
nowadays where their their production
budgets are so inflated they're so
through the roof that it makes it really
hard to make a profit nowadays
especially when you're producing these
movies and granted it's like a lot of
people are saying how you know this
we're living in a time post covid and
after covid things really changed the
way how people respond to theaters go to
theater so no one's making these like
billion dollar hits anymore and yada
yada it's like a rarity now and
the thing is a lot of these movies were
scheduled to start filming and whatever
while coveted was happening before covet
happened so they're in this weird box
here yeah same time I'm like I don't
think you should have made Indiana Jones
in the dollar destinations
why would you make it Indiana Jones
movie for that much like not even it
makes no sense to do that for Indiana as
big as big of a legacy of that franchise
is the box office numbers that they've
got them before are not enough to
Warrant that kind of production budget
yeah how did you add a joke since the
title of Destiny and it's kind of like
that for a lot of movies and that's why
a lot of these movies are losing so much
money because
their their production budgets are so
insane and we're just talking about the
production budget it's not even the
marketing you know I do think marketing
is important I think I think it's so
important I know that's what I'm saying
is I think the production budget needs
to be looked at as much or more than
marketing budgets I think marketing
budgets people need to hear about these
things know they're out they need to
know why they need to see them I think
that like both need to be scaled down
but if there's anything it's like why
300 million to start like we need to
look at the production yeah and and a
lot of these movies are also so freaking
long yeah and if you were to cut down
the the run time like in pre-production
on the script
that would trim your budget yeah too
because like every minute of film that
they put that you see shot is so many
crews so many hands on deck so many
hours it can be so annoying and boring
being on a set because you see like they
spent a whole day shooting five minutes
is a great day yeah this is a great day
you look at it you look if you go on set
of something and they're like all right
so uh what do we have they have the the
script supervisor showing the notes and
it's like it's like five to ten pages
and you're like oh that's it yeah
this should only take 16 hours you know
five and ten pages is an ambitious day
that's like exactly yeah that's a soap
day it could be a page and a half and
like you could be on a Fincher set maybe
half a page so it but if you don't get
the coverage then the movie's garbage so
you have you have to find that mitigate
loss yeah
um Daniel Bryan fan okay we've got some
secret Invasion comments here my
prediction of secret Invasion after
Talos and fury conversation in the car
is that Nick Fury dies in the end and
somehow is in the Marvels and Talos
takes on the mantle of Fury
how interesting would it be if that
whole time it's been Talus that we're
watching in the Marvel's trailer to keep
his legacy alive also it is not a bit of
an a-hole move of Earth to expect half
of Asgard but not want to help Scrolls I
mean they live in an already
uninhabitable places because of the
radiation as Guardians have super powers
and from what I gather Scrolls have been
shape-shifting but aren't extra strong
unless they become super Scrolls
I feel like Earth doesn't know about
Scrolls yet so they can't welcome them
yeah but why are they acting like
they've been so repressed then uh I
think they're afraid because they can't
just come out and be like we're scroll
we're green what up yeah I think there's
also like a bit of a commentary on like
you know obviously it's a commentary in
refugees but how people's appearance
affects how they're treated uh I think
there's a definite commentary on like
you know the green skin being something
they're afraid to show so I think that
will come to pass as being addressed as
the show develops because they've
already been very forthright about the
racial commentary of Nick Fury I think
there will be some of that commentary at
the Scrolls so I think what you're
describing will be addressed uh as we
get deeper into it but I don't know
um where they'll land as home but I
think that's the exciting part of the
show is like what part do the Scrolls
play in the greater MCU going forward
uh so here's a story guys what do you
got
in my wife's car there's a mysterious
mascara wand oh is that what that item
is yeah I didn't know what it was okay I
don't wear mascara obviously for a
female yeah
and um it's not hers okay so it looks
awfully suspicious that's fair
when it's
when I took her card this morning to go
work out oh did you I was like where
does this type
and I'm like I don't know where it's
came from I thought it was a Q-tip
I got no answers
it's hard being a guy
constantly being accused you're just
like I don't know where this came from
maybe it came from something else man
got six
you guys have to react to my adventures
with Superman it's amazing I heard great
things about this I love Jackman like I
really think what is Jackman Jack quit
Jack as in Jack oh I love Jack I love
Hugh Jackman uh no like
van was like a character I love Jackman
Jackman no I think Adventure Superman uh
is such a great idea because like Jack
Wade is such a good voice actor also
perhaps in a long Halloween part one uh
but I think his Superman is gonna be
delightful and the animation looks great
um maybe that'd be fun say hotels
Jackman Jackman Hugh Jackman uh Sammy
boy uh we already did that one so I
think we're all caught up on the stream
Labs next time when we have a streamlabs
the uh audio you could do would be like
don't cross the stream
oh good call I love that yeah that's
hilarious I'm just saying it's at the
ready
my next podcast should be buzz cut
biceps nice haircut man appreciate you I
I mean we could see we could I feel like
the Marvels could be about the Scrolls
and something oh I think in like the
crease girl War would be a fascinating
thing to do because that's very Captain
Marvel based the cosmic elements all
that thing
how great would it be if they got Colin
Farrell to return dude I'd be so happy
you guys know how much to learn as
Bullseye yeah I really want Nick Cage to
return his Ghost Rider First I'm also
very close in that haircut uh I think
that would have I I really think they
could get Nick Cage to return I think
it'd be fantastic truly like Nicholas
Cage being such a comic book guy would
love that would be at on time yeah we
spread clothes it's 1 45 and we said two
should we oh my God yeah uh yeah we're
an hour and a half into the stream okay
yeah let's uh
give people like a five minute warning
no this is the warning now we're gonna
turn off the super chats everyone really
quick koi just so we make sure we're not
lying in the title how do you feel like
everything will change
oh with Deadpool yeah uh well I mean
someone already disagreed to be in the
chat but I think most people agreed I
think this is the Avengers level event I
think it is going to be not only the end
of fox continuity which is huge as I
said earlier a studio ending is insane
especially one as big as the fox X-Men
Universe uh I also think it is going to
be all the cameos people have wanted
from this multiversal stuff so I think
it'll change the scope of expectation
versus reality but most of all it's
going to bring in one of the biggest
Flagship characters into the MCU this is
a Spider-Man level event meets an
Avengers level event meets a Multiverse
level event all in one movie and it's
probably going to clear the path for
both X-Men and Fantastic Four I don't
know if they'll introduce an X-Men in
this movie that are going to be the MCU
I don't know if we maybe get a passing
of the torch from one Wolverine to the
other it'd be very interesting if we
have uh you know 10 Wolverines played by
Hugh Jackman and then there's a new one
in a post-credits scene perhaps
literally passing a claw baton uh I
don't know if they'll introduce any
member of Fantastic Four but this is
both a conclusion and a launching point
so this is going to change everything
but we also in the opening uh of our
little Salvo we talked about Superman
which is obviously going to change
everything DC do you want to talk about
that as well yeah uh please about the
Superman because that obvious I think
the implications of how Everything Will
Change starting with that are pretty
obvious but please but while we're here
uh I think that Superman is the hero
that DC needs and I think it's probably
the hero that we as a culture need if
you guys haven't seen my video about the
difference between what I think Zack
Snyder Superman's going to be as well as
James gunns I'm really proud of that
video like I I really believe in it and
then recently we did a Superman video
between backstory out in a minute uh
here but what kornswets I'm gonna go
Korn's wet here um what he represents as
the altruistic aspirational Superman I
honestly think as a culture we can use
if you look at the world we keep making
these reflections of ourselves which
obviously art reflects our life but we
don't have a lot of aspirational content
I think the reason Ted lasso so went
from being like what's that soccer show
to oh my God it's a phenomenon is we
want to feel good imagine the scope of a
superhero movie like Avengers but with a
character like Ted lasso that just makes
you want to be a better person Superman
wants us to be better he thinks he can't
be enough and he tries to be everyone
all the time everywhere all at once I
think we need a movie that is like that
I think we need something that we should
aspire to I think Guardians made me cry
like a baby because James Gunn
represents a lot of us and feeling like
found family and underdogs and all those
things and if you put that in the lens
of Superman if you put that with you
know the horrors of what Metallo or uh
Brainiac could mean for AI commentary
what Lex Luthor could be for
billionaires that are going to be doing
cage fights in our actual reality while
they're racing to space and dying in
submarines there's a lot of really
interesting things about how horrible
horrible our world is with late stage
capitalism juxtaposed with how much we
need hope and that's Superman and that's
Lex Luthor and that's the villainy so we
need Superman now more than ever looking
at you with this haircut is like
stepping into a time machine of what I
would first see you on the internet this
has got this when I saw you at the door
today I'm like I feel like me again yeah
like this is who I was so nice before we
knew each other keep looking at you like
this is like when I first watched koi on
the internet this is kind of crazy I
feel so much more like me it's really
it's chirping me out a little bit not
gonna lie
um pre-reject koi the real reject needy
Poe need he Paul oh what thought a
generous Genera generosity
it's the internet but I'll I'll touch
myself to to
boatloads of cash
if I had a Walter White little storage
full of illegal drug money my old phone
background was Bill Burr laying on a
stack of money from breaking bad as a
manifestation was he the other character
there yeah dude I don't remember that
being they'll burn the daughter got it
yeah
I didn't remember that they're both
stand-up comics uh Vince Gilligan I
always hired day players with stand-up
comics uh love you guys
I've always loved DC Marvel and Star
Wars but never knew how to express that
love with the word until I found you
guys really
I'm honored koi has so many words too
many and you just gotta take a fraction
of that then you will learn how to
express it Duality dichotomy y'all have
given me yeah John coming here with
percolating dread
I was at a party on the fourth of July
and this person heard me use a bunch of
words that they'd never heard before and
started giving me crap literally asking
me to do like a game of like what's a
word for this what's I've never been
treated like a puppet before but it was
kind of fun to test my thesaurus you
know you're doing koi I like Words
um
you'll have given me so much comfort
through a tough year oh I'm sorry to
hear that you had such a tough year
practice the attitude of gratitude I
want to get a tattoo that says that I
like that attitude gratitude or be
grateful
be grateful you negative piece of [__]
is what I wanted yeah
read that every day I'm just saying
uh shout out to correct fabulous curly
hair
my hair a lot not about Greg's hair
enough it's Majestic the headband the
whole tie-in it's beautiful I know
somehow I've embraced the headband it's
so buoyant hair has always got such like
bounce to it
Greg you're definitely that dude thanks
I really want to say what does that mean
that dude's like uh you're like him as
the kids saying you know gen Z's always
saying like he's him and I'm always like
that's a weird redundancy I need to get
in touch with the dinner well thank you
needy I mean talk to the youths
I mean yeah I mean this whole chat the
great thing for the longest time I
didn't know how to put an award
especially when it came to reactions I
didn't really quite know how to put into
to words what it was that people liked
about the channel honestly I was like I
don't know what people like about it
this is kind of like silly what we do
and uh but no I mean it's just uh all we
do is it's a form of expression is all
it is and and [__] like he had no idea
how much anxiety I had about putting out
slight negative not even negative really
just a mixed bag opinions about mission
impossible so when you're just like holy
crap this movie has 130 on Rotten
Tomatoes two two brief behind the scenes
one doubling down on something I said
earlier and one about the behind the
scenes of the Superman thing that I
forgot to mention uh Greg I was over
here and the Superman news broke Ed Greg
and I literally spent 40 minutes like
going like is it is there enough is
there things to talk about and then we
realized because of like you guys that's
tying into what I was saying earlier I I
said very clear as day like this is my
favorite place and it's not because I
don't like working with Christians not
because I don't love working the rock
stars I love working with those people
it's largely because like when I do uh
capes and cows with Christian it's the
three of us hanging out which I love and
it's like a social Gathering and it's us
like talking and like I've become such
good friends with Christian and Winston
and I love those guys for doing that
show but it's because that feels like
it's us and then we just put it out
there and then like new rock stars feels
like a reporting news and we're hanging
out we're just putting it out there this
feels like it's actually interactive and
that's not disparaging any of those
places and I know that's what's gonna
get clipped out and I I get that but to
me it's about like this live chat you
guys are like actually people whose
names I recognize these are actually
like a community and it feels like our
Expressions our reactions are received
as opposed to people judging them like
they're you're always going to remember
the negative comments always that's how
the human brain works it's pattern-based
it's survival based it's it's run from
the Tiger but overall when we react here
I don't feel like I have to put on and I
also don't feel like I have to like take
myself down a Peg and then it's really
unique and wonderful so every place I
work has a different feeling the reason
this is my favorite is because it's a
safe environment to be you and I love
that yeah I I want that to be the case
so I appreciate you saying that koi
because uh yeah I mean we came to
Superman video like I had barely any
thoughts on that was so funny I was like
all right I don't really know them like
I'm like yeah they look the part that
was my opinion I was like I don't want
to do a video and then I was like oh
you're probably gonna talk but you got
like two minutes and then and then
eventually it was like Gonna Roll the
camera
and then I had him stop I'm like maybe
we could just do it in a live stream
and then they're like all right just
don't don't roll the camera and I was in
the middle of there's a meeting happen
there was like far for the other thing
we were working on had four other people
in the in in the home and I was like
right in the middle of a meeting that
was really important super important
meeting
and and then um you stepped into the
meeting because you had to be a part of
it and then I was like well dude like
okay well why do you what I I just asked
Coy like why why are you ex what do you
like about why tell me why you like this
news
you spitballed for like a minute and a
half then I was like all right roll
again I just roll the camera then I was
like John let's pay a little bit extra
money if you went because normally if
it's like if you're not prep editing I
edit and then
then John has an edited video a month so
I was like all right John if you edit
this I'll pay a little bit extra money
so so we literally were in this room and
it was I loved about it was Greg was
like I don't know if that's enough and
then I was like here's this and they're
like oh that is immediately enough yeah
and so I ran in here and what I love
about doing those comic Corner videos is
they're usually like one take me just
spitballing and it's really fun to be
like I feel like I get to be the kid in
the comic store but for you guys like
that kid in the back of the comic store
that's just like hey if you guys want to
read I got these books and like he's not
welcome anywhere but he's welcome here
and that's that's what's been great
about doing it it's fun to find people
and see what makes them shine and try to
like bring that out of them yeah that's
the power of the internet that's what
the internet should be is finding like
the Internet connects all of us and
instead of using it to hate on people
and instead of separating into tribalism
why not find that person you can't find
in your town and your community and your
friend group and like draw them into
your life via the Internet like this
should connect not separate
all right koi now we need to give
efficient
but quick answers both efficient and
quick ready
it's a little redundant I'm with you
sufficiently quick efficient qualitative
answers
yeah uh
Johnny thank you would you buy tickets
to a great movie that over three or four
hours with him without an intermission
how many hours is too much for a movie
well here's what I would say to that uh
wait a minute I don't get the question
would you buy a ticket to a great movie
then without an admission without an
intermission
um oh my God uh I would prefer without
an intermission honestly I'm not a bit I
know you probably want intermission
because this guy always has to pee like
like every 10 minutes big hydrator and
then it whenever we could see a movie
together I'm like here's what happened
while you're gone that's true you're
fortunately you're fast too like you
you're it like you don't leave for that
long
um and uh it doesn't matter how far away
the bathroom is
you guys ever see me
the movies on and uh so I'll be able to
catch up but I feel like in a I think if
you're going past three hours it's
success it's too excessive from my point
uh like to me that's where it's at uh I
personally think movies should tell
whatever story they set out to tell and
run time shouldn't impact that but there
should also be an understanding of the
cinema experience which is the there are
ushers that work there they're
concessions that work there there are
people that actually run the theater in
the exhibition industry and I think the
longer the movie the more it affects the
bottom line of the box office because
you can only actually put as many movies
in a certain house if the theater's open
for 11 hours and the movie's over three
hours and you only get three run times
that affects the box office it depends
on the movie yeah but the Snyder cut I I
easily could watch that in one sitting
surprise of course az's next movie is a
great example fire Josh said uh you know
like what's that called that Killers the
flower moon is going to be I think four
hours they say that's gonna affect its
box office and I think people don't
think about that when they're building
the movie but you also need to tell the
whole story so I'm up two months Apple
movie is it yeah oh wow I didn't know
that I just thought it's expensive
Christopher wamoff we got a 20.
keeping us efficient
[Music]
chat yeah we are Chris Wham off love you
one of our top patrons too koi is having
a fight club screening at his place
today very excited about it
um that is as a fact so good job 80s
model
unrelated I just been wanting this
haircut forever and then I was like
Now's the Time
Jay Fernandez thank you so much Jay
Fernandez
hey guys I hope that your weekend is
going great are you guys satisfied with
James Gunn's half DC reboot we haven't
really seen it
I am satisfied with information I have
heard thus far
um but no they put a question mark on
them Robert Downey Jr
we don't know either and we addressed
that we didn't know we addressed that we
weren't sure but here's the information
on that we did talk about it uh I hope
you're I I cover my ass with the
question yeah you're like wait a second
we do not clickbait here at the real
rejects uh are you guys satisfied
reboot
reboot uh no I mean I we don't really
know much about it honestly I think I
think when we see Blue Beetle that would
quantify I guess as a half DC reboot I
also think they have to cover their
butts with trying to make the bottom
line back so I think that flash isn't
necessarily tied in but they were saying
it might be because if it had done well
it would have been but I don't think
it's going to be now that it didn't do
well so I think James gone is presenting
you've never had a universe end like Fox
did but still keep going like it's not
like the fox mutants ended but Fox still
was gonna make x movies James Gunn got
handed the keys to a car that was
already running I'm just saying go drive
so like he's gotta park the car and
figure his own car out before he like
launches it again so I think uh there's
gonna be some ups and downs there's
gonna be some tuning there's gonna be
some messiness but overall I'm very
excited by the announcement but we won't
know what it feels like until it's going
well thank you Jay
thank you crashing coyote
thank you for the Super Chat I think
koi's half right oh sucker I think it's
going to be Deadpool trying to save Fox
universe but ends up causing their
deaths each time Final Destination so
that that is a fun spin on it yeah
that's kind of that's kind of what I was
speaking to is like him killing the fox
Universe I don't think it's conscious I
think he's gonna be killing the fox like
Punisher no because I think that'd be
too dark to bring him into the MCU like
I imagine they were like you love these
characters but it's kind of like the
Montage of X-Force right but spread out
but and all accidental because that
would tie into the end of Deadpool 2 and
the X-Force continuity and it would be
like what have I done incursion events
and it'd be a lot funnier if he was
accidentally like killing a hundred
Logans that would be funny so I agree
with you crashing coyote if I didn't
make that clear I think that is more
it's gonna be a funnier Kills the Marvel
Universe then oops I murdered them all I
don't think there's like the beyonder
hired him to murk people
how great would it be though if we ended
up getting like Toby Maguire or
Spider-Man the original try to cross
them over at one point right how great
would it be if they did get like Toby
Maguire to cameo in that or Andrew
Garfield
I would be more excited about Toby I
would be Andrew's way more the right
tone he's actually funny but no I'm
saying that that Toby's Spider-Man would
be the rewarding one because that's
someone they wanted to cross him over
with right right right right but I think
I'm wrong about that was it Toby's well
Hugh Jackman was Toby's yeah yeah but
I'm saying tonality wise I think Andrew
Garfield and and Ryan Reynolds are more
that totally I totally get that but I'm
talking like for the moment yeah yeah I
mean for the I think Hugh Jackman and
Toby would be hilarious but I think
Andrew Garfield and wait and Ryan
Reynold would be great yeah yeah plus
them making out at the Oscars be funny
if they did that in suits true oh that's
true they also have that yeah that's
true that's a good point Snogging
Spider-Man Deadpool age-appropriate Tom
Holland Marcus Santos thank you so much
my friend
have you guys hear about my adventures
with Superman yes we have heard about it
here it's good it's a new series in the
animation for it is so awesome uh that's
a big maybe on the list how long is the
run time because that'd be great what is
the episode run time
for
The Adventures of Superman honestly like
when you get into a show and and if it's
like a low performer it really like like
affects the whole Channel it really does
like I saw with the [__] Witcher I
don't realize how bad that was and for
you guys not on the YouTube uh space
like I don't really know the algorithm
and stuff I'm not good at that thing
that side it's my job but but that's
what I'm saying is like I didn't realize
that if you do like say your reaction
Channel and you start doing reviews and
the reviews don't do well then
all the reviews won't do well like the
channel the YouTube will be like they
don't do reviews well here that's not
fair yeah it's kind of a weird it's a
weird and it's always changing too and
they don't like announce it yeah you
gotta like find out some way like after
damage has been done like what the
hell's going on oh it's already broken
thanks it's broken uh that's a maybe
though that's a maybe it's definitely
been on my mind though
Deadpool stream turned into a DCU stream
God damn right we talk about everything
here yeah appreciate that Collide
appreciate that
that's a 20 what am I what am I thinking
come on now
oh
there it is
you always interrupt only only sometimes
that apart I know I forget because I
Jesus it's on me the whole point of it
is the Marriott
with the two Super Chat and you're just
always like subscribe as if I did
anything by just clipping Ryan Reynolds
audio but work went into me timing and
the sound mixing it did actually make it
balanced I've only interrupted three
times
Luke day 04 been watching the channel
for Years love from the UK
oh
thank you thank you
I appreciate that thank you
um it's a great question Wesley Marshall
thank you so much uh Coy now part of the
reason why
uh I mean part of the in
conception of being like koi and John
should do this DC animated was I was
well aware that koi hadn't really seen
them because koi had a hard time
connecting with animated
and
I just know John hadn't seen them and so
and I was like what I know John doesn't
really have as much of the comic
knowledge right so I was like this would
be a fun pairing if you get a comic
knowledge expert someone who's trying to
get more into anime and I was like but
those first two I'm like I know those
first two are [__] amazing so this
will definitely hook koi I think this
would be a great start so one thing that
hasn't been addressed is has your con
has your connection to animated
properties change at all
now you've done so much coverage here
with them hugely actually uh I've
actually found myself watching more
animation at home I watched this great
movie uh Intergalactic uh which I think
Curtis Mason uh recommended who was in
the chat earlier but I I've been
watching more animation recreationally
because of how much it's actually like
brought me in I I didn't have
that foolish concept that animation is
only for kids I've always seen it as a
medium not a genre I've never been one
of those people that's like ah animation
I just had trouble connecting with it
because for me there's something in the
actor's eyes there's something in the
soul of the actor that I connect to with
the character and that's why when
casting is good I associate all the good
work the actor has done with that
character like I'll always see a Tom
Hardy movie because of the collected
work of Tom Hardy that I appreciate in
the character by default I don't feel
like that with animation when I see an
animated character I don't go man I
connect with that black pair like the
the hairline in Batman now I go oh
that's a character that I've connected
with in the past Damian Wayne and Bruce
Wayne have the same hairline in all the
DC animated movie universes that they
share and now I'm finding these
connections that I'm actually drawn to
where I'm like oh this is this Batman
much like I did with actors and uh the
comic book medium for me is always
magical because the space between the
panels is what I love I love that comic
books to me represent the closest
through line between the soul of a
writer and the soul of an artist to to
the consumer because when you read a
comic if you look at the credits there's
so many less people than a movie movies
are long credits because there's
thousands of people that's only like a
tenth of the people that worked in the
movie by the way whereas a comic it's
like you know the editors and the behind
the scenes people but it's really two or
three people that are bringing you that
art so it's so much more of their soul
and I'm starting to feel like that with
animation where you're connecting to the
voice actors in a different way you're
connecting to the animators who are
giving you the way they perceive the
world and one of the reasons I've always
loved Rob liefeld is Rob liefeld's world
is so extreme I know a lot of people
give them crap because the way he draws
is so 90s and like people like to judge
it I've always seen Rob liefeld world as
that's how Rob sees the world is Extreme
so he draws how he sees the world you
can look at Rob's photo realistic stuff
he does portraits that look like the
world but that's not how Rob sees the
world and now with animation I'm seeing
it as this beautiful characterization of
what someone's perception of the world
can be I'm starting to get into anime
I'm starting to get into uh the way
video games are made more so this is
actually helped me connect to a
different medium in a way that I love
yeah whatever
yeah
that's okay yeah I think um it's an
answer it was an answer Chad gbt wrote
that answer
oh I've been deep and written
Sidra is Haiti
there's a rumor that Channing Tatum
filmed the Gambit Cameo see to Deadpool
3. we've talked extensively about this I
would love for it to be true I feel like
it is true
I hope that doesn't
I hope we don't see it I hope it doesn't
get ruined me too
that is one I would love to avoid a
spoiler I would love to not see him in
the trench coat until it's like done
you know what I mean like I'd like to
see it on screen how far how long have
they been filming this for uh like sure
they're wrapping like in a week
really yeah the movie's almost done how
quick did Hugh Jackman bulk up we
haven't even seen this photo no which is
impressive I think because that thing I
think he's in the suit for a lot of it
that's cool yeah I think they're filming
on stages for a reason I think there's a
lot of stuff I think they rap in a week
yeah oh really yeah I think I've been
filming like two months Jesus really
yeah if this comes out in seven months
somebody's out like it's so fast right
this movie's out soon
I'm really worried the rider strikes
gonna affect it I'm I'm not gonna lie I
stay scared I have really this is my
most inspirated movie I can't not be
afraid I'm really worried it's gonna
affect it man
uh Collide next stream is gonna be next
weekend Sam the man lee thank you I just
want to say I love you all we love you
all three thousand we love you all three
thousand as well thank you Sam the manly
hey
unnamed film Channel your last panel I
asked where you think Marvel would look
like if Disney never had any association
I also wanted to ask are you think an
Avengers level film will look like in
that case he was at our wonderful yes
panel I remember that question that's a
great question that's when I started
talking about like oh I remember the
Netflix series and that's kind of what I
think Marvel could have looked like a
little bit more well you think an
Avengers level film would look like in
that case ooh what an Avengers level
film look like if Disney never bought it
um I don't think it would be as bright
in color I think the first Avengers is
what it needed to be you know what it is
I think it would have been kind of like
an Infinity war movie
but not as bright it's the best way I
could summarize it's actually a script
for fantastic foreign X-Men crossing
over Fox tried to do that before
everything fell apart there's actually a
too dark I think Ghost Riders in it I
think they'd like I think they really
did the damn thing um I I've never read
it I've just heard Legend of it I think
it would have been more R-rated I think
it would have been more gritty I don't
know if it would have worked because
that Fantastic Four in that Ghost Rider
I don't I don't know if they would have
meshed as well as Marvel made the world
mesh they knew how to make things that
felt a little bit more mature instead of
just family friendly like I watched
Fantastic Four Rise of the Silver Surfer
and I was surprised by how much of an
improvement that was on the first
Fantastic Four movie like the first half
hour a little rocky but as it went I was
like I'm really invested in this like
I'm taking this serious and I'm I'm
actually kind of gripped uh by what's
happening here and obviously the extra
movies are some amazing films there as
well so I do think that and then of
course like this Toby Maguire Spider-Man
movies Andrew Garfield ones there's
there's a world here where yeah it's
like you could feel the Disney touch now
um I like the Avengers movies but I'm
not exactly sure what
I don't think it would have been as like
Easter egg heavy I agree I also think
that because not even the X-Men movies
do like Easter eggs not not to that
level yeah like there's um like Gambit
like the name Gambit pops up on its
computer screen and stuff but I also
think that
um I think a lot of people liked I saw
in the on the chat someone was like I
think there would have been more comic
book accurate I also kind of like that
as comic book fans we get something that
isn't as comic book accurate I talk all
the time about translation versus
adaptation I think Civil War being so
different and then reading the Civil War
comic is more rewarding because I'm not
like oh this is familiar they both get
to feel like their own complete things
so I kind of like that Marvel and Disney
are doing their own thing and I think
that like Deadpool movies improved the
Deadpool comics in a lot of ways so I I
think I think both have their pros and
cons and I think that uh it would have
looked very different but I I think it
all worked out for the best overall yeah
as much as I missed Netflix
Theodore Harris
[Music]
good agents MC phase four has introduced
and further fleshed out different super
beings who do you think is physically
stronger the cree the squirrels the tele
Canal or super soldiers oh I like this
question that's really nice rank them uh
Cree teleconneal physically strong
skrulls than super soldiers nope super
super soldiers yeah super soldiers and
Scrolls so in in my head Canon Cree
telekineal super soldier Scrolls uh I
think Super skrulls are gonna be
on par with the crease so the cree
scroll War can happen I think that's how
the crease scroll war is going to happen
but for now that's the three you think
we're gonna get the cree squirrel War I
think Captain Marvel might end with it
the Marvels
really they seem to love the cosmic it's
just gonna like end with that they got
so much other [__] happening
I hope not but I feel like they they
mean they've set it up kinda I think the
you know if they've got secret Invasion
dealing with refugees and people being
without their homes yeah they're gonna
be like why and then they're crazy
they're like we're going back to war
I could see it happen
do you think it's gonna flop
I worry about everything because
all the budgets are so insane we talked
about a little earlier I think we're
entering a different era of filmmaking
we're streaming really hurt movies like
people don't realize that if 20 people
share a password which they're cracking
down on like I'm not supporting I'm not
supporting budgets being as crazy and
thus you have to go to the movies but
the movie industry requires the movies
and I think that's gonna really shift I
I mean
it's not just streaming it was like the
same day and date release [__] that they
were doing oh there's a reason Warner
Brothers the fact that you can get these
like massive movies just like Oh Black
Widow I could just buy it on Disney plus
yeah like no that that [__] up the
whole association with cinema right for
sure and the Warner Brothers like hey
tenant just put on HBO Max and like
there's a reason Nolan's like I'm gonna
go over here to Universal and make this
epic over here
thank you it's corin's wet not Corin
sweat wet not sweat corin's wet corens
Warren's wet balls
way better got you just slightly dipped
Corin is wet
he should put a hyphen
come on David we got the man should put
a hive it's worse than Schwarzenegger
that's why the that's why the briefs you
need to keep your corns wet corin's wet
line of demise oh no from a comic book
they give the line of demise from the
comic book comes my favorite line about
Gotham you're going to need your
sunglasses once it gets dark
what from a common events
I don't understand I don't give that a
line I think he's just saying that's his
favorite line from a comic but what does
the line mean I don't know is it a
riddle but it's ominous like
I don't I don't if it's dark why would
you put your sunglasses on
I never liked that Trope like Blues
Brothers it always makes people look
weird like people with sunglasses inside
I don't trust them people do it in
movies but in real life you're like this
freak this guy what do you think he's in
The Matrix yeah only people the majors
can do it that that actually looked cool
the whole time that was that one time
felt Justified for some reason yeah and
they never explained why it's not
brighter maybe they saw through the code
and it was too distracting because they
saw the ones and zeros like we gotta put
sunglasses on
laughs
[Music]
raccoon shampoo
oh I like scream a little more but I
respect the jigsaw choice I like how
that that's a good hierarchy
what do we got what do we got
oh I'm talking to yours you didn't
interrupt cool I didn't let's rub my
nips
raccoon says the important question
what's the context for the mandatory
James Gunn dancing going to be in
Superman Legacy
I've only danced in two of James Gunn's
movies
dude they're dancing like four
Guardians one
two three
I think it's a guardian Suicide Squad oh
Peacemaker Peacemaker yeah but that's
opening credit it's not in the show
and The Suicide Squad they didn't dance
I think it's a Guardians thing and an
opening credit thing
I don't think there was
I don't think there was dancing in super
or in
I don't know if it's I don't know maybe
Scooby-Doo there was probably dancing in
Scooby-Doo I've never seen Scooby-Doo if
there is dancing and super what
had processed that it took a second uh
if there's dance against Superman Legacy
I hope it involves Jimmy Olsen because
he isn't shot in the face
that's all I know I think him and I
think Lois and Clark could have a dance
I'd love that like a sweet dance yeah
like a slow dance in Kansas like they
got a little Smallville moment and
they're like you know bells of hay and
stuff do that classic uh they're flying
in the sky
with a nice needle drop yeah that'd be a
great use of Dance Turn Down for What
yeah shots shots
or he's dodging bullets while they're
I think that'd be a good one yeah I
oh did he he danced in Peacemaker and
not just in the credits you're right
touche in that uh Second episode that
show's so good yeah I'm gonna reject
[__] damn v900
a young Superman while Damien is the
robin still feels like a mistake to me
since there's no John John Kent
can't do the super stones with John and
Damien which made Damien a lot more
likable huge missed opportunity
um okay so John Ken is Superman's son
and in continuity they have him leave
planet for a while which ages them up
and that puts him around the same age as
Damian there's a lot of messy continuity
in all comic books for that is
especially messy uh I don't think you
need Jonathan Kent for
Damien to work because that's like a fun
parallel world's finest right it's a
commentary on young Superman young
Batman you have them growing up together
and it's a fun way to reintroduce
world's finest we've never really had
world's finest in general so I think a
30-something Superman and a early
40-something Batman is our first World's
Finest negating the need for John Kent
and Damian I think Damian is more a
commentary on what it's like if Bruce
Wayne gets to use his paternal side
because Superman you know has always
been paternal Bruce Wayne has never been
paternal growing up without parents it's
a beautiful way to see that Bruce has to
develop a side of him that doesn't solve
problems with punching it's a great way
to be like oh this guy doesn't just
fight everything Damien Wayne tests that
side of him Damian Wayne's also a
commentary on what if Batman was pure
Vengeance what if Batman just saw the
world as broken and he's like you know
the grandson of Rosal Ghul who thinks
killing is acceptable versus Bruce Wayne
killing is never acceptable Damian Wayne
represents the ID gone awry in Bruce
Wayne so I think that juxtaposition is
way more important than the John Kent to
me and I think we're still going to get
a beautiful world's finest commentary
via uh having very similar age Clark
Kent and Batman
I don't think anyone's chomping at the
bit to have a John in there no I don't
think John Kent is uh By Request I think
we can accept the fact of how we can
have a Damien right now or some type of
a robin because we've had so many
Batmans that have that have worked and
been successful and really connected
with audiences yeah I think that's where
where's the Superman Journey has been so
up and down lately like um like we had
Brandon for a movie and you know we had
we had Henry Cavill with the craziest
shirt he ever was like what's Happening
Here for years and and then now it's
like we just need to have a clear-cut
establishment there before we can get to
a John Kent yeah I think we have to earn
a Superman first yeah
dead shot thank you would you guys be
down for Matt Reeves doing both hush and
the court of owls in his Universe also
do you have hope for the new alien movie
I always have hope for a new alien and
or Predator
alien yeah someone I thought it was a
show uh the Noah Holly oh is it the Noah
holy one I thought that was a show okay
I thought an alien thing just wrapped it
might have been the show I just I'm uh I
don't know I don't know I just hope
Ridley Scott leaves it alone because
Jesus Christ man uh but what you guys
you down for Matt who's doing both hush
in the court I mean I feel like Court of
owls for sure yeah I feel like they set
up both in the in the last movie they
had that big hush written out in front
of uh like it was about hush bunny but I
think hush has been teased uh I think
Court of owls is maybe the third movie
like it's been like percolating the
whole time like long game but I would
love I think that's the kind of thing
the Batman is better for I think totally
the Batman is more this world whereas I
wouldn't really want to see Court of
owls with like the family I think that's
better suited for the more Supernatural
characters
there is a movie Deadshot set fady
Alvarez is doing an alien movie
did he really yeah they just wrapped I
just said the Alvarez I just saw the rap
photo on Instagram I think
yeah
that's gonna be gory that's the right
direction I think after the Prometheus e
stuff
damn fatty Alvarez yeah that could be
there could be a gut punch he did do
that Dragon Tattoo sequel that no one
really liked that's true but he also did
that great Evil Dead didn't he yeah
don't breathe I don't like I'm not a big
heart guy but that evil Dead's fantastic
yeah packs a punch I think Court of owls
is inevitable yeah for that
hush is a great opportunity I think hush
works better for a little bit of an
older Batman though so I think he would
that's like a four or five to me I'd
love that not not a two or three because
he needs to be a long time since he was
year one which is like he's year two
right now he needs to be I agree I think
hush works better for down the road
raccoon shampoo thank you also did you
see the suicide squad
psyche no oh the there's an anime
Suicide Squad I did see this it looks
pretty cool yeah just dropped this week
the the trailer uh there's an anime
Suicide Squad with like a very big
production comedy that does a lot of big
animes see I've been I've been watching
more animation because y'all uh yeah it
looks awesome and like I love the Joker
design I don't really love the old
Harley Quinn design as much now that
like the characters develop but since I
assume this is from the older them
together I was cool with it but the
animation looks gorgeous
that's good to hear yeah
Austin Daniels thank you Austin Butler
as Gambit love it that's a great choice
it's a little too obvious but it's a
choice that's a good choice
damn that that is that's really good not
to see it now hey I can picture him in
the trench coat I can hear his voice is
perfect
um
Haley Lou Richardson as Rogue for MCU
Gambit is a very slept on character in
my opinion
I don't know why it seems like hard for
people to get Gambit right like it seems
like a note
character yeah and he's got like a cards
like it's not about explosions and
charms yeah it doesn't seem like a hard
character to get down like it takes not
I'm not saying it doesn't take effort
sure I'm just saying that out of any
character it's not a character that's
difficult to Fathom adapting that's the
part of it that I I can't like why is it
so hard to bring this character to life
for people like I think it's interesting
that we have so many movies about
Charming criminals but it's never worked
with the Charming criminal of movie of
comics like get guy Richie on a solo
Gambit movie
it seems so obvious to it's just I mean
yeah no I don't know I don't know what
it is I don't know what it is Addie in
the chat it would be really cool for
quite to watch my hero Academia not even
for the channel but just for quite watch
it I've watched seasons one through four
and I have reviews up on my channel for
all of them you're that far into it yeah
I'm about to watch season five I loved
four it's such a good show for four is
great it's what I want X-Men to be on
Disney plus I think they are the bar for
team Dynamic power sets I'm so impressed
the image
dead did I skip any I'm making sure
no okay dead shot thank you thank you
Cameron Monahan is MCU Cletus with
Richton Brock oh that's fantastic
cameramanahan is such a talented actor
an actual redhead Cletus Cassidy would
make me happy uh and Richardson I mean I
haven't watched Jack Reacher these guys
have but he is like he looks like Eddie
Brock like that guy is I went to the
fast X Premiere and everyone in that
movie is jacked and this guy made them
look tiny like that guy is so big I'd
love that for Brock that's really fun I
loved his choice I didn't quite pick up
on what it was saying but now then you
explain got you yeah okay Venom Carnage
yeah yeah
absolutely Alan richson is Eddie Brock
yeah because when I when I imagine Eddie
bra from the comics he's always like
super jacked and he's got to make Tom
home look tiny yeah and then like that
with the Symbiote man that'd be awesome
I mean Alan Richard really showcases I
mean he's in some DC show I forget which
one but he really showcases his acting
prowess uh Hawkins okay yeah he really
showcases his acting prowess and uh and
and reach her for sure he's a fantastic
actor and he also showcases like how he
can play hyper intelligence as well yeah
I think he'd be a really good Brock and
cameramanahan is one of the most
talented young actors work he is a slept
on actor I don't know why he doesn't get
more work
kind of pissed me off he's amazing yeah
he's real real good you should be
awesome name
real good should be a household name
real good real good turn on the tube
change the channel
everybody knows him his household name
turn the volume up hey keep it down back
there watching Shameless hunt
I love your mama too
Jenna Ortega Zatanna would be great
Captain to me oh I love that I love that
praying that one day this happens I feel
like she's uh definitely one of those
names that gets tossed around a lot on
purpose like I feel like Jenna Ortega is
for all the right reasons everyone's
like darling I would love being wasted
in something like I could see her being
I could see her being one of those
people who's casting something don't
utilize her right yeah yeah that's the
one Pitfall I'm worried that she might
fall into especially if you put her like
in some Ensemble people right I want her
to be a hero that gets her own movie but
also can play in a team I'd love justice
league dark to be you know zatana first
then Constantine then Swamp Thing and
they build to justly dark with Jenn
Ortega Zatanna like as a team and solo
one of the oddest things about the X-Men
franchise to me is how they got
oscar-winning actress Halle Berry to be
storm and not you just barely a presence
in any of those movies they tried like
forcing it a little bit in Days of
Future Pastor like bring her back it's
Halle Berry and in part three they try
to like make but that was such a
terrible movie and she's the leader of
the X-Men like there's two X-Men teams
she leads one of them and like the storm
Solo movie is my most anticipated not
yet green lit movie like I think storm
needs a movie and that is one of the
things about you know
um having t'challa die in the MCU that
is kind of sad yeah I mean kind of
there's a lot of reason to be sad about
it in terms of comics story so you're
not going to get that storyline of of uh
Aurora Monroe unless uh Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars and the MCU as we know it
Bucky Barnes Atlanta
um
I mean okay so apparently there's gonna
be a Star-Lord Solo movie
did they confirm that I don't know I
mean they said Star Lord will return who
knows that's all I know right uh but
Bucky Barnes who holds down the chats
here random but excited about the
legendary Star-Lord news
yet I hope it's a Disney Plus show
instead of a movie hope you all are
doing well
what would it be
him and his dad his grandpa hanging out
yeah judging the neighbor yeah I don't
know what a Star-Lord without the
Guardians is uh I love you know
Star-Lord I just can't imagine is it him
acclimating to Earth it'd be cool if
it's an earth Adventure yeah I want to
see Earth yeah like I don't want he's
done otherwise it's gonna just be like
it's like when they did pirates four
right you're just like so it's just like
there's just no the there's just no
Elizabeth Swann and it's kind of weird
per Capstone
yes this is just yeah no I want him on
Earth yeah yeah but do it him on Earth I
think that would be the way to do but
still you could do some Cosmic thing
where you feel and then he's it seems
like he should have it handled because
it's just him on Earth yeah but he
actually somehow was more of a fish out
of water okay I got this Star-Lord on
Earth Fish Out of Water for the first
few episodes then the Avengers call him
because he's the only one who knows
about celestials yeah we finally get the
celestial sticking out of the planet
problem solved because starlord's like
guys I got you right and then he joins
The Avengers on Earth yeah I think
there's a way to do it where he should
be at home but and he should be the most
capable but somehow he's he's got Cosmic
experience he's got nowhere no Earth
experience yeah and that's fun he only
knows 80s references yeah yeah that
would be really fun like he's really out
of time here yeah like big you know like
a fish out of water but because time
Star-Lord number one on my Scrolls list
guys well that's interesting Rizzo 258 I
need a coin John reaction to my
adventures with Superman yeah you do
I mean maybe I I hope it's doing well
like I don't know how the show's
tracking but like I would love that like
if that show's doing well I have no idea
yeah I haven't I haven't heard I just
know Jack Quaid's the best I have no
idea I mean it's tracking people are
liking it you know but yeah it's really
easy to get misled into thinking like I
mean what's it's like yeah what's the
popularity yeah but I do want to put Coy
and John on Teen Titans go to the movies
oh that's fun into that have you not
seen it uh I've seen pieces of it
Oblivion radio
gave us a heart I want to shout that out
and then lastly we got a couple of super
chats here I'm random Ram
all right
here we go last two last two of the day
let me just make sure okay
reloading reload
no we gotta oh [__]
all right coin looks like you got
yourself two and a half speeding through
you got two and a half hours today
uh people outside my house waiting to
watch Fight Club what's happening
what time does it start oh I told people
to come over 3 30. I don't know it's 2
30 man I gotta clean
did he clean last night I did but I want
to finish
behind the scenes on my life
I need to push mine to collab we're both
crushing it but we're both very good
time awareness
um let me read level uh
all right all right I'll read this
dichotomy that's true it works all right
okay I got this everyone shut up
everyone be quiet
I'm so hungry same
I had like such a heavy workout before
here and then I didn't eat and now I'm
like oh I'm really feeling it what was
today uh there's chest and uh biceps and
triceps rot chest and biceps try
subscriber
it's like a whole T it's a lot
yeah all right yeah look I'm trying to
be coy
not not the you know the Personality
yeah not shy
games look at me being cool I'm so quiet
did you see all the comments actually
you didn't because Mission Impossible is
aggressive but everybody was like man
Greg looks great and I was like correct
those alone comments I responded to
yeah you know I told you I don't want to
know any of those comments look they're
they're positive it's about you're being
jacked I want to hear one comment I was
the second half a tough quiet you can
read it I don't want to know anything
here I don't know any comments runs away
I haven't looked at it at all I'm gonna
expose myself to this [__]
um doesn't have an unpopular opinion
really ain't cool uh where are we at God
damn it people are saying Jensen being
Batman when it happened because of his
age every time we get close I mean he
looks great though yeah Tom Cruise is 60
and he's diving off of space into Earth
all right he's doing fine every time we
get closer to the movie I can't imagine
anyone other than him in the role what
do you think also especially next to
corn sweat balls uh yeah dude I
there's a lot there's so much this would
be such a great fan fulfillment the
thing with James gun if James was
directing it I wouldn't be as confident
right because James Gunn's always like
who's been with a little weird pickup
but
um
but I think yeah but I think um Jensen
Ackles is is such a Converse such a big
topic of conversation and he tends to go
against the grain would choose with who
to choose I feel like he would at the
very least let him test for it I is
perfect I I don't think his age in this
case like he could not know Batman from
their 15 years easy but what is his
height oh I think he's tall because uh
Jared Padalecki's very sure Jared like
he's very I think he's at least over six
feet yeah yeah Jen snackles Batman
co-signed
for sure for sure Danny and Shane do you
know anything about the Superman villain
Manchester black and do you think that
is a character James come and introduced
as a Future Villain let me tell you
about Manchester black all right
he was born by the Sea
true uh Manchester black I think could
be because they're introducing the
authority in the Superman movie I think
Manchester black was recently in a
Superman vs Authority for issue
miniseries so there is like recent Canon
for Comic fans I also think it's a
character that juxtaposes a lot of what
Superman's beliefs are because he's kind
of a a gun for higher mentality not
fully but Superman's all about altruism
he's more about what you can do if you
are willing to sacrifice all your belief
structures so I think Manchester black
could be introduced as a long-term
foible for the beliefs of Superman I
don't know if he'll be the main villain
but I can see it happening as an
introduction to uh the authority
can you guys fathom we might actually
get a brainiac I really think we will I
think it's coming oh crazy with that I
think Metallo Brainiac those are topless
or like a 20th Lex Luthor either that
either way either one
either way Lex is in it but it might not
just he needs life he'll be there he's a
part of the universe but he's Palpatine
in this I want him like elongating yeah
but brainiacs we might get up we're so
overdue like that is a Justice League
level threat yeah and it's so topical
yeah
look at the secret Invasion opening
credits
Tyler
love watching you guys hey
who are your picks for the new 838
Illuminati
I assume that's what he means by
illuminate yep also koi what are your
overall thoughts on the Doomsday Clock
event well I think Doctor Strange should
definitely be a part of that Illuminati
I think you should get iron hard on
there
I think you should that'd be funny I
think all the things that we're waiting
for
uh
and uh Ralph boner should be part of the
a38 Illuminati
um just just Patrick's uh Stewart's dead
body from One Division should be part of
the eighth just him and his chair yep
and then they're weaken at Burning him
to make it seem like there's more
Reverend seats but it's uh McAvoy doing
it like I'm so fortunate like a
multiversal Xavier playing with Xavier
because he's like turning into Onslaught
that would be really funny uh I think
that ends Cassie link
uh I think you could do like a really
fun thing with the uh Illuminati being
other comic Illuminati and like
characters we'd never see again that's
kind of like when they put John
Krasinski in there there was no
intention of having him play read so
what if that's how Robert Downey Jr
returned that he'd actually been a part
of the Illuminati this whole time oh I
love that that's actually I love it
that's fantastic and that's good for cap
four because of all the yeah
Espionage
is great love that
that he had to fake his death yeah in
order to keep the world not fake to
death but he had to keep pretending to
be dead or he had he did die and he
reached out to a multiversal self
because he already knew about it like
there is a Multiverse yes yes and that
way you Downey like the only the only
person
yeah the only person Tony Stark trust is
Tony Stark there you go that's how you
do it that's cool I like this that is a
cool way to do it remember this when
they do it when they do it that's how
they we theorized it but I was going to
say like Wanda blows his head off like
use Black Bolt again but have it be Vin
Diesel dude do the fun like fun casting
for eight three eight like
uh and then overall thoughts on Doomsday
Clock I personally like Watchmen
separate I think watchmen's a commentary
on DC I think it's weird to have them in
DC I think Rorschach meaning Batman all
that's fun but like it's very
elseworldly to me I didn't love the
event it was paced well and it was fun I
just don't personally consider it Canon
that's fair
hey hey pyronic gaming
what are you what characters are you
most excited for in the DCU mine is
personally Nightwing but I'm interested
to hear your thought I mean you took my
answer Nightwing is the one who I when I
really got into reading comics when I
was younger it was Nightwing
um the current runs so good dude if you
want to read any comic like right now's
Nightwing is maybe the best he's ever
been in the comics I I like the hunt for
Oracle has never left my soul uh Tom
Taylor's writing Nightwing and he did
the Injustice run that turned into the
oh really yeah okay he's and he's not
tall you have to say uh and I only read
what's relevant to what's coming out
that's it you know how I roll there's
too much going on quick I only read 70
bucks oh yeah
um and uh I am I'm very excited
personally for the authority I think
that is such a James Gunn wheelhouse and
it's gonna be something that surprises
people Authority is the one I'm most
anticipating I'm a little bit
apprehensive I mean
I would say James Mangold Swamp Thing
sounds really cool yeah I'm very excited
Swamp Thing yeah uh Nightwing's a huge
one for me I want to see detective chimp
that feels very James Gunn it hasn't
been announced yet but I think we are
going to get a detective champ because
that is very much his thing uh in the
DCU that we have not been announced I
think justice league dark is what the
thing I wanted from the prior duration
of DC the most so I've kind of like held
on to that so I really want to see that
kind of corner of the world uh I would
love to see a new poison ivy
um I of mine of DC you guys probably
know this but Mr Miracle is my favorite
DC character uh I want to see uh Mr
miracle in the new God element but also
like the darkness of Mr Miracle will be
represented uh and then lastly he
already said Swamp Thing I'm gonna go
with uh plastic man I think he's a great
source of Comedy that is so weird and
wacky that it would help DC feel more
like it's got versatility in it you know
he said there's no plans for the suicide
squad too which really bummed me out
because I rewatched The Suicide Squad
Fair Guardians and I'm like God damn I
loved it yeah pains me that there's not
a sequel and development
Larry we got a 10 we're almost done here
guys
okay hear me out since we're talking
about African Gardener returning his
Daredevil Elektra for Deadpool 3 what if
favro gets a cameo he gets to kill his
foggy is happy in Deadpool three or some
funny Cameo between the two I think a
fabric I was weirdly thinking about John
Favreau when I was working out so weird
thing because of his role in friends as
a UFC fight I don't know what made me
think about John Favreau when I was
working out but it was like this weird
thing where I was thinking about his
work in Couples Retreat and how every
time he's in a movie he always plays
some kind of like
like a horny weirdo or uh I respect I
haven't seen the movie Chef but yeah so
good it's like a horny weirdo or just
someone Chef or just some guy who kind
of gets clowned on yeah right but then
he's also this like respected director
and a big part of nerd culture yeah he's
he's like an Iron Man and Mandalorian
you know and like it's it seems like
such an op and he's like made Jungle
Book and Lion King you know like it's so
weird the on-screen actor personality
the characters he takes on versus
running is yeah I'm like what a what a
dichotomy yeah right of of of of like
not representing at all what he's liking
you know of just truly capable of
because he never plays someone with that
much Authority or intelligence
for him yeah like like uh Christian Bale
is such a jolly guy and he always plays
the scariest guys like Christian Bale is
like a Welsh Santa Vibe and Christian
Bale's always like ah it's scary and I
feel like John Farrell
like I'm always like this schlubby every
man but you're like literally
Reinventing Star Wars Marvel like he
reinvents entire world I mean uh I would
love that foggy uh also I think it'd be
really funny and I don't know if this
could ever happen but Kevin Smith in
Deadpool because it doesn't happen
because Kevin Smith's in Daredevil and I
would love to see Kevin Smith get to
much like the Stan Lee cameo in Captain
Marvel if Stan if Kevin got his flowers
as an actor in Deadpool I'd love that
that's my big Cameo Kevin Smith I would
love that I love that idea Quinton just
want to say
what do you want to say
you know because we haven't used this
one enough okay you'll get your rent
when you fix it damn chat
it's good it's good
I just want to say thank you koi for you
know what I should do for these live
streams just a little background music
oh a little royalty-free
a little elevator line the whole time
yeah a little music like when you're in
a grocery store yeah yeah yeah just
really distract the audience like it I
like to love it just want to say thank
you koi is Quentin Tarantino by the way
introducing me into reading comics I've
not been able to stop reading even now
I'm reading comics it's an addiction
it's become a problem my family has said
I should check into a rehabilitation
center due to the excessive reading I
keep doing long-term sleep reading
comics
um I've just finished the Ultimate
Spider-Man run the clone saga issues and
holy [__] if they ever made that into
live action I would freak out I could
not love this comment more thank you
Quentin I just want the medium to thrive
so you're reading comics means the world
to me Ultimate Spider-Man I think is the
most approachable comic book around of
all time it also lasts a long time so if
you if you get in it you can live in it
for a while I think it's the thing that
helped Marvel come back I think it's the
thing that helped Comics come back
because it's one of the big two Thrive
uh and one of my favorite fun facts
about the Ultimate Spider-Man comics is
it was supposed to be a mini series
which by the pacing the first three
issues is so different from the rest of
the run and that when Brian Michael
Benda started writing that comic he had
a desk by the second episode a second
issue he was writing it on top of his uh
filing cabinet and the third issue he
was writing it on the floor but by the
fourth issue they got their numbers back
and they started buying back equipment
again Marvel was in such bad shape they
were selling equipment and that comic
really helped turn things around I don't
I don't know if people realize how
precarious every art and medium is a lot
of people are always like oh movies will
always be fine come Comics will always
be fine they're better off than a lot of
people say because the Doom and Gloom
always gets clicks but they're also not
infallible that's why artists are
important that's why all the AI stuff's
scary that's why all of the people
saying like I'll just steal this in
Pirate it don't understand what they're
doing if you love art support art Comics
almost ended and Comics are doing better
now but you never know what impact a
story you pick up has Ultimate
Spider-Man is a great example it was a
mini series that turned into an entire
universe that turned into Miles Morales
that turned into across the spider-verse
that turned into one of the best anime
movies of all time that turned to the
best one of the best Eagles of all time
and all of that is because of comic
books so please read comic books please
love this medium that I love please
support movies and TV if you love them
and thank you I'm so glad that I could
uh I could gift you that that bit of art
that you got to consume and enjoy
it's the hair guys it brings out a new
side of me I feel more mean it's the
hair it's just this is me again it's not
quite it's not ranting it was love but
it was a positive rant if it was a rant
at zero rants today what's a word for
positive rent
um zealous diatribe okay
[Laughter]
much love nicely done all right ladies
and gentlemen
um Coy stayed here a lot longer than he
was supposed to that's what happens when
you get super chats you keep us live
streaming everyone all right this was
fun love this before we go let's get
around here your channel still pulled up
there my friend let's get a round of
quick quick little goodbyes in for
everyone as I readjust this Bryce Bouche
I think you're gonna say is that uh
Jalen Lugo nerd girl Jean Tracy uh uh
Nick Vasquez you tell him thanks man
pause the rant oh I like that uh Angel
of Death uh that was Llewellyn
uh JB lifestyle Flex I've had reacts
saying hey j616 all right I think that
is a good little stream because it
slowed down to the 30 seconds I read too
fast JB lifestyle oh my God such a nice
comment much much appreciate if you guys
for joining us what's love big D Big D
if you guys can leave a like on the way
out that'd be very much appreciated we
talked about every topic that was
featured here we did we did you you
eventually said what thank you for
holding down the chat here too Bucky
Barnes you said why everything will
change right oh a lot there was a part
in there yeah no I got it that was with
an explanation but not a question mark I
got it okay good Perfect all right
awesome all right another live stream
next week we're gonna be rank uh ranking
the DC animated movie universe so if you
have any questions over there that'll be
next weekend yeah yeah let's do that all
right thanks guys leave a like and a
comment and also leave a like on the DC
animated videos what you guys want us to
get into next and Saturday one o'clock
Saturday one o'clock San Diego Comic-Con
and the library will be there we'll see
you there much love rejection oh my God
you're gonna make nerdy girl faint thank
you Bryce thank you everyone bye